I would like to encourage us, as a community of 7 million C++ developers around the world, as we consider C++'s future, to push the boundaries to bring C++ itself forward and double down on C++, not be quick to switch to something else. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 97 recorded on September 25th, 2022. My name is Connor. And today with my co-host Bryce, we talked to Sean Baxter about C++, Carbon, Circle, and CPP Front. We've got bidirectional is the infinity sign. Omnidirectional is the circle. Dario is the overlapping Venn diagram. And cardioid is the...
我想鼓励我们这群全球 700 万的 C++ 开发者，在考虑 C++ 的未来时，能够突破界限推动 C++ 自身向前发展，全力押注 C++，而不是急于转向其他语言。欢迎收听第 97 期 ADSP 播客，录制于 2022 年 9 月 25 日。我是康纳（Connor）。今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起，采访了肖恩·巴克斯特（Sean Baxter），探讨了 C++、Carbon、Circle 和 CPP Front。双向的是无穷大符号。全向的是圆形。多里奥是重叠的维恩图。心形线是...
Okay, which one do I want to be on? Probably omni or yeah, omnidirectional. Okay, I'm sorry. Connor, Connor. There are Probably Omni or, yeah, Omni Direct. Okay, I'm sorry. Connor, Connor. There are four symbols. Oh, yeah, right, right. The circle, the circle, the circle. It's topical that this is a perfect segue into having Sean Baxter.
好吧，我想选哪一个？可能是全向的，或者，对，全向的。好吧，对不起。康纳，康纳。有 可能是全向的，或者，对，全向。好吧，对不起。康纳，康纳。有四个符号。哦，对，对，对。圆圈，圆圈，圆圈。这很应景，是一个完美的过渡，接下来我们要请出肖恩·巴克斯特。
Better not be Cones and Robs. All right, so we should introduce our guest yeah Bryce you can take this introduction hang on my dog is staring dead into my eyes right now
最好别是 Cones 和 Robs。好的，我们该介绍我们的嘉宾了。对，布莱斯，你可以来做这个介绍。等等，我的狗现在正死死盯着我的眼睛。
I am here in my lovely Manhattan apartment with Sean Baxter the creator of the Circle Compiler, which I personally think is the future of C++. Sean, maybe you should introduce yourself. Thanks for the introduction, Bryce. Hi, Connor.
我正坐在我可爱的曼哈顿公寓里，旁边是 Circle 编译器的创造者肖恩·巴克斯特（Sean Baxter），我个人认为他是 C++ 的未来。肖恩，也许你应该做个自我介绍。谢谢你的介绍，布莱斯。嗨，康纳。
I'm here to, I guess for a really aggressive interview, it sounds like. Yeah, that's correct. An adversarial one. I'll try to, it sounds like. Yeah. Embracerial one. I'll try to stay in my toes. Yeah. Did you listen to the last episode? Because what happened when, I'm not even sure I'm allowed to mention it, but I was asking Bryce if we were going to talk about some topical news
我来这里，感觉像是要接受一次非常激进的采访。是的，没错。一次对抗性的采访。我会试着，听起来是这样。是的。对抗性的。我会试着保持警惕。是的。你听上一期节目了吗？因为当，我甚至不确定我是不是被允许提及此事，但当时我在问布莱斯，我们是否会讨论一些热门新闻
that had come out in the last previous week and then about a sort of successor to C++ kind of area. And then he was like, oh, do you mean jacked? Or no, first he said, oh, do you mean Val? And then I said, no, you know I don't mean Val. And then he said, oh, you mean jacked? And then out of that, he said, oh, we should bring on Sean Baxter, because Sean has looked at all of the languages
这些新闻是前一周发布的，然后涉及一种类似 C++ 继承者的领域。然后他就说，哦，你是说 jacked？或者不，他首先说，哦，你是说 Val？然后我说，不，你知道我不是指 Val。然后他说，哦，你是说 jacked？接着由此，他说，哦，我们应该请肖恩·巴克斯特来，因为肖恩研究过所有
that are supposedly going to replace C++ and has opinions to share, including obviously... I think more importantly, before everybody decided they wanted to make a successful language in C++, like predating it by like three or four years, Sean decided he wanted to make C++ better. Yeah, and for the... I make C++ better. Yeah. And for the, I mean, we should, yeah,
号称要取代 C++ 的语言，并且有话要说，其中显然包括……我认为更重要的是，在每个人都决定要在 C++ 中打造一门成功语言之前——比它早了大约三四年——肖恩就决定让 C++ 变得更好。是的，而且为了……我让 C++ 变得更好。是的。而且为了，我的意思是，我们应该，是的，
do like, you should introduce yourself a bit for any of the people that haven't listened. You have, I think, two different interviews, one on CppCast and one on CppChat. And I distinctly recall being in Sunnyvale and I think I was either on a bike ride or on a run when I was listening to that CPP chat episode. And I like, I was like floored because they were just, you were just talking
做个自我介绍，给那些没听过节目的听众听听。你好像有过两次不同的采访，一次在 CppCast，另一次在 CppChat。我清楚地记得我在森尼韦尔（Sunnyvale），当时我要么是在骑自行车，要么是在跑步，正听着那一期的 CPP chat。我当时惊呆了，因为你们只是在谈论
about how you had written a C++ compiler, like single-handedly by yourself. And I was like, wait, what? And you were, and then I think it was like, I can't remember. Yeah, it was probably the CPP chat one. And the hosts were just like, well, let me get this straight. Over three years, or I think it was two or three years, you just single handedly by yourself. Like, meanwhile, the other people implementing compilers are teams, scores of people, and you just did it single-handedly so anyways you can right so it's been six years now that i quit my job i have this epiphany about compilers and i thought like the initial idea was to rotate the language from the compile time into the runtime domain or rather let me say it again to rotate the language from the runtime to the compile time domain so what used to be code that you could build and execute at runtime, you could evaluate it through the interpreter at compile time. And that way, all the standard library and pretty much all code
关于你如何独自一人、单枪匹马地编写了一个 C++ 编译器，当时我就想：等等，什么？然后你，然后我想那是，我不记得了。对，可能是 CPP chat 那期。主持人们当时就说：好吧，让我弄清楚。在三年里，或者我觉得是两到三年里，你单枪匹马、独自一人完成了它。与此同时，其他实现编译器的都是团队，有几十个人，而你却独自完成了它……所以，不管怎样，你可以……没错，所以自我辞职到现在已经六年了。当时我对编译器有了这个顿悟，我想——最初的想法是将语言从运行时域转换到编译时域，或者更确切地说，让我再说一遍：将语言从运行时域转换到编译时域。因此，过去你只能在运行时构建和执行的代码，现在可以通过解释器在编译时进行求值。这样一来，所有的标准库以及几乎所有的代码
would be available to you to use for compile time programming. And that was the impetus. So I have a meta token that you can put in front of a statement, and it'll evaluate that and create that object at compile time. It doesn't care about constexpr or anything like that. You can have mutable state, and it kind of blurs the line between a compiled language and an interpretive language.
都将可供你用于编译时编程。这就是动力所在。所以我有一个元标记，你可以把它放在语句前面，它会在编译时对其求值并创建该对象。它不在乎 constexpr 或类似的东西。你可以有可变状态，它某种程度上模糊了编译型语言和解释型语言之间的界限。
It's still statically typed. It still generates object code at the end. But now you have access to a greater you know, a greater vocabulary of functions and types to do your work. So you can open a file at compile time, read in data, and then kind of reflect on that data to emit code programmatically. And that was, you know, that was the original idea. And it was actually a really great way to start writing a compiler because I didn't have to worry about LLM at the beginning. I could just use the interpreter and evaluate my own source code at compile time. So that was an easier way to bring it up. So instead of having to worry about a front end and back end building both of these
它仍然是静态类型的。最终它仍然会生成目标代码。但现在你可以访问更广泛的——你知道的，更丰富的函数和类型词汇来完成工作。因此，你可以在编译时打开一个文件，读取数据，然后对这些数据进行反射，以编程方式生成代码。这就是，你知道的，最初的想法。这其实是开始编写编译器的一种绝妙方法，因为一开始我不用担心 LLVM。我只需使用解释器并在编译时对自己的源代码进行求值。所以这是一种更容易将其启动运行的方法。因此，不用担心前端和后端，不同时构建这两者，
simultaneously, it was like, I'll just build the front end. I'll try to consume all of the, you know, STL headers. I'll try to consume other open source projects to get this thing built. Instead of worrying about emitting object code, I could just run it inside the compiler. That was a good way to bring it up. That's
我就想：我只构建前端。我试着消费所有的，你知道的，STL 头文件。我试着消费其他开源项目来把这个东西建起来。不用担心生成目标代码，我可以直接在编译器内部运行它。这是将其启动运行的好方法。这
pretty amazing. I want to go back to the first part of that amazing story, which is you quit your job. You believe in this so much. Just take me through that. You had such conviction in this, that this needed to be built. Right.
太惊人了。我想回到那个惊人故事的第一部分，也就是你辞掉了工作。你对这个信念深信不疑。带我回顾一下那个过程吧。你当时对这个东西有如此坚定的信念，觉得它必须被造出来。没错。
I didn't really know what was in store for me. And I'm not sure I would do it again. But on the other hand, I think it's kind didn't really know what was in store for me and I'm not sure, I'm not sure I would do it again, but on the other hand, I think it's kind of in my nature to do this. Yeah. Um, it's been, I mean, it's been like really difficult. Um, and I haven't had any money. I haven't had any income since then. So one motivating factor behind this is just like, I don't want to end up penniless and
我当时其实并不知道等待我的是什么。而且我不确定自己是否还会再这样做。但另一方面，我觉得这其实……我当时其实并不知道等待我的是什么，而且我不确定，我不确定自己是否还会这样做，但另一方面，我觉得这有点符合我的天性。是的。嗯，这一直，我的意思是，真的非常困难。嗯，而且从那以后我没有任何钱。从那以后我没有任何收入。所以这背后的一个动力因素就是：我不想落得个身无分文的下场，
with nothing to show. So I put a lot of pressure on myself to produce. So I don't get bogged down in problems. If I see a can of worms, I do not go open it. I try to stay productive and I just try to write code. And I have this sense of just being able to cruise through any issue. And I think I've always had that kind of conviction. It's just a matter of willpower.
却一事无成。所以我给自己施加了很大的压力，逼迫自己产出。这样我就不会陷入问题中无法自拔。如果我看到一个潘多拉魔盒，我是绝对不会去打开它的。我努力保持高效，我只是试着写代码。我有一种能够冲破任何问题障碍的感觉。而且我觉得我一直都有那种信念。这只是个意志力的问题。
So if you have the idea and there's an idea that's attractive and if you can sum it up with willpower, then you should go and do it. I didn't have any other, you know, dependence or anything like that, so I might as well follow my dreams. That makes things a little bit easier. Yeah, but I think since then Circle has evolved a lot and it's gone a lot of different directions. So I've had two distinct pattern matching implementations.
所以，如果你有一个想法，而且这个想法很有吸引力，如果你能用意志力来支撑它，那你理应去把它做出来。我当时没有任何其他的，你知道的，负担或类似的东西，所以我不如去追随我的梦想。这让事情变得稍微容易了一些。是的，但我认为从那以后，Circle 已经有了很大的发展，并走向了许多不同的方向。所以我经历了两个截然不同的模式匹配实现。
I've had a shader. I embedded the GLSL OpenGL shader language into C++, and I can emit the Spear v intermediate representation, which is used for Vulkan and OpenGL code. So you can program any of the 12 shader stages in C++, just like you would CUDA. I have a CUDA target, and at CPP Now, I gave a keynote on pack metafunctions and enhanced parameter packs at JOR. It was a great talk. I loved the talk.
我有一个着色器。我将 GLSL OpenGL 着色器语言嵌入到了 C++ 中，并且我可以生成 SPIR-V 中间表示，它用于 Vulkan 和 OpenGL 代码。所以你可以用 C++ 编程任意 12 个着色器阶段，就像使用 CUDA 一样。我有一个 CUDA 目标，在 CPP Now 大会上，我发表了一场关于包元函数（pack metafunctions）和增强型参数包的主旨演讲。这是一次很棒的演讲。我很喜欢那次演讲。
I was sad when people had so much constructive criticism afterwards, but I thought it was a great talk. Yeah. I mean, I'm just trying to explore different language ideas. And some of these are really radical. I don't think any of – like, these things I'm talking about aren't things that will appear in proposals. And there's certainly one thing that – they're not things that are likely to be standardized. But are they radical? Or are they radical for C++? And I ask that like if C++ was a younger language or if C++ was evolved like some other languages are, would some of these proposals be seen as radical as they are in C++?
当人们在会后提出那么多建设性的批评时，我很难过，但我认为这是一次很棒的演讲。是的。我的意思是，我只是在探索不同的语言想法。其中有些想法真的很激进。我不认为有任何——就像，我谈论的这些并不是会出现在提案中的东西。而且这肯定是一点——它们不太可能是被标准化东西。但它们真的很激进吗？还是说对 C++ 来说它们很激进？我这么问是因为，如果 C++ 是一门更年轻的语言，或者如果 C++ 像其他一些语言那样发展，其中一些提案还会像在 C++ 中那样被视为激进吗？
I don't know. It's hard to say. I mean, we are where we are yeah um yeah so uh do you want to like pivot to the uh successor language question because i think that i have a few i have a few other uh this is gonna be awesome because i'm just gonna sit back and let bryce this and so i'm just gonna get like an advanced preview screening of this interview here. Okay. So next discussion. So Circle is not open source.
我不知道。很难说。我的意思是，我们处在现在这个位置……没错。嗯，所以……你想不想转到“继承者语言”这个问题上？因为我觉得我还有一些……我还有其他一些……这太棒了，因为我只要坐下来，让布莱斯来主导这个，所以我将会提前看到这次采访的预览版。好吧。那么下一个讨论。所以，Circle 不是开源的。
Right. And I think a lot of people maybe find that surprising in this day and age. Can you maybe explain why it's not open source? Yeah, I don't want to have to respond to people. I need to be able to sit back and think about things. So for the last, like, three months, you know, two or three months, I've been thinking about generics. And I have to be able to tune everything out. And the idea about if you open source it and you have, like, pull requests and you have all these demands on your time.
没错。我想在这个时代，很多人可能会觉得这很惊讶。你能解释一下为什么它不开源吗？是的，我不想必须去应付人们。我需要能够静下心来思考事情。所以在过去，大概三个月里，你知道，两三个月里，我一直在思考泛型。我必须能够屏蔽掉所有干扰。关于开源的想法是，如果你开源了它，你就会有拉取请求（pull requests），而且你的时间会被各种需求占据。
This is still a research language, even though it's a full compiler. It's 275,000 lines. I've run a lot of test weeks through it. For me, it's still about exploring ideas. For me, I want to spend my time developing ideas and I think responding to users. There's so many odd demands that I can't satisfy. So I'm just trying to do the best I can. And at the same time, I feel like I don't owe anybody anything right now.
这仍然是一门研究型语言，尽管它是一个完整的编译器。它有 27,5000 行代码。我在其中运行了大量的测试套件。对我来说，这仍然是关于探索想法。对我来说，我想把时间花在开发想法上，而且我觉得回应用户……有太多稀奇古怪的需求是我无法满足的。所以我只是在尽我所能做到最好。与此同时，我觉得我现在不欠任何人任何东西。
It's not open source. I'm not taking anyone's contributions. This is giving me more freedom to build a tool and take it any which way I want. Right. Because making something open source is sort of the act of giving away some degree of control over what happens to it because then you have contributors that come in. It's the commitment to support kind of a community even. Yeah.
它不是开源的。我不接受任何人的贡献。这给了我更多的自由去构建一个工具，并按我想要的任何方向去发展它。没错。因为把某东西开源，某种程度上就是放弃了对其未来走向的某种程度的控制权，因为那样就会有贡献者加入进来。这也是对支持某种社区的一种承诺。是的。
Even if you just have like a few contributors, it's still a demand on your time. And, you know, I like having kind of high level conversations with people if they have features they're interested in, like, I'm, you know, happy to try to implement things and see how they how they feel. So I like kind of interacting at that level. But yeah, I it's, I think it would really slow the process down if I had to kind of give people a stability guarantee as well as pulling in their contributions. The ability to like just change the- Sorry, the dog was tearing at something she was not supposed to be tearing at. Moony, come here.
即使你只有几个贡献者，这依然是对你时间的占用。而且，你知道的，我喜欢和人们进行那种高水平的对话，如果他们对某些特性感兴趣，比如，我很高兴去尝试实现这些特性，看看它们的实际感觉如何。所以我喜欢那种层面的互动。但是，是的，我觉得，如果我还必须给人们稳定性保证并吸收他们的贡献，这真的会放慢整个过程。那种能够直接改变——抱负，那只狗在撕扯它不该撕扯的东西。莫妮（Moony），过来。
Continue talking. Welcome to ADS Be The Podcast. It's really gone downhill since the beginning. continue talking oh welcome to ads be the podcast it's really gone downhill since the beginning you know bryce likes to have his dinner while we record you know the dog is like a basically a third co-host at this point okay we got okay the dog is on bryce's lap now like yeah a small child. Because the dog was trying to eat her dog bed, which I've had to sew up holes in that dog
继续说话。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客。自从开播以来，节目真的是每况愈下。继续说话。哦，欢迎来到 ADSP 播客。自从开播以来，节目真的是每况愈下。你知道的，布莱斯喜欢在录音时吃晚饭。你知道的，这只狗在这个时候基本上就是第三个联合主持人了。好吧，我们有——好吧，狗现在坐在布莱斯的膝盖上，就像一个小孩子一样。因为这只狗一直在试图吃她的狗床，我已经不得不给那个狗床缝过三四次洞了。
bed three or four times. She really likes pulling stuffy stuff. The last statement about open source is that since I don't have any source code users, I'm free to refactor the code continuously, which I do. And you can't really have an open source project
她真的很喜欢扯里面的填充物。关于开源的最后一点是，既然我没有任何源码用户，我就可以自由地持续重构代码，而我也确实是这么做的。你其实不可能搞一个开源项目，
where the internals of it change so rapidly. It just breaks everyone's downstream projects. So for me, at this point, it's important for me to stay nimble and to myself. But it is for Liabeau, right? If you want to use the binary. Sure. And it's interesting. Connor and I last week talked about
其内部结构会发生如此迅速的变化。那会破坏所有人的下游项目。所以对我来说，在这一点上，保持敏捷并专注于自我对我很重要。但对于可执行二进制文件来说是这样的，对吧？如果你想使用这个二进制文件的话。当然。这很有趣。我和康纳上周谈论过
another... The K programming. Yeah, the K programming language, which is another language that is developed by a single visionary person. It's not open source and it's just released in a binary form.
另一个……K 编程语言。是的，K 编程语言，这是另一门由某个富有远见的人单独开发的语言。它不是开源的，只是以二进制形式发布。
And I think there's sort of many similarities to that evolution story. Although, interestingly, with the K language, there's different versions of the K, or different evo... Not versions, but evolutions of the K language. And when the guy, Arthur Whitney, decides that it's time for a new one, he deletes all the source code for the old version and starts over and deletes all the binaries. And it's just – it's completely from scratch. Well, that's a 30-year-old project. I don't think I want to go for that long. Yeah, yeah.
我觉得这和它的演进历程有很多相似之处。不过有趣的是，对于 K 语言，有不同版本的 K，或者不同的演进……不是版本，而是 K 语言的演进。当那个家伙——阿瑟·惠特尼（Arthur Whitney）——认为该出新版本时，他会删掉旧版本的所有源代码，从头开始，并删掉所有的二进制文件。这完全是从零开始的。好吧，那是一个有 30 年历史的项目。我想我不会持续那么久。是的，是的。
And then the final question or topic. So you use LLVM as the backend in Circle, correct? Yeah, I have some others as well, but primarily LLVM. So can you maybe explain a little bit about how LLVM is used in Circle? Because I think a lot of people maybe hear about Circle and they're like, oh, it's got to just be an extension of Claim or something like that, which it's not. Right, it's not. Yeah, so it's notlaim or something like that, which it's not. Right, it's not. Yeah, so it's not based on Claim at all.
然后是最后一个问题或话题。你在 Circle 中使用 LLVM 作为后端，对吧？是的，我还有一些其他的后端，但主要是 LLVM。那你能不能稍微解释一下 LLVM 在 Circle 中是如何使用的？因为我想很多人听到 Circle 时可能会想：哦，它一定只是 Clang 的一个扩展或类似的东西，但事实并非如此。没错，不是的。是的，所以它不是 Clang 的东西之类的，其实不是。没错，不是。是的，所以它完全不是基于 Clang 的。
It's a completely... There's no Claim dependency. It's unrelated to Claim. LLVM is Intermediate Representation. It's like an abstract version of Assembly, and it targets a virtual machine, the low-level virtual machine, and there's instructions like you would find in an Intel or ARM assembly guide, but these are for this abstract machine. And then you emit code for this IR and
它是一个完全……没有 Clang 的依赖。它与 Clang 无关。LLVM 是中间表示（IR）。它就像是汇编语言的抽象版本，它的目标是一个虚拟机，即低级虚拟机，里面有一些指令，就像你在 Intel 或 ARM 汇编指南中能找到的那样，但这些是针对这个抽象机器的。然后你为这个 IR 生成代码，
LLVM lowers it. So it's really a portable assembler. It leaves up to you the responsibilities for binary interface and kind of understanding the requirements of the operating system. It's very low level, but it's like, I just, yeah, I target the LLVM IR, but I don't have any claim to benefit. Gotcha. All right. Now.
LLVM 会对其进行降级（lowering）。所以它实际上是一个可移植的汇编器。它把二进制接口的责任以及理解操作系统要求的责任留给了你。它是非常底层的，但就像是——是的，我的目标是 LLVM IR，但我跟 Clang 没有任何利益关系。明白了。好的。现在。
Should we stick on? Cause we got over like what? 10 minutes, 10 minutes into this recording. Cause if we want, we can chat about, or should we switch to the next topic? There's nothing more we want to say okay you said if we want we can chat about and then there's a dot dot dot there we want we can chat about what oh like continue to talk about circle for a little bit because we're going to slice and dice this up if you want to talk about carbon uh no let's talk about circle no i i mean what I've been doing is related to that. So it's, if you want to go in that direction.
我们应该继续吗？因为我们已经超过了——什么？录了 10 分钟，10 分钟了。如果我们愿意，我们可以聊聊，或者我们应该切换到下一个话题？没有什么更多想说的了吗？好吧，你刚才说“如果我们愿意，我们可以聊聊”，然后有个省略号……我们想聊聊什么？哦，比如继续多聊一会儿 Circle 吧，因为如果你想聊 Carbon 的话，我们可以把这段切碎重新组合……不，我们来聊聊 Circle 吧。不，我的意思是，我一直在做的事情就跟这有关。所以，如果你想往那个方向聊的话。
Should we? What do you think, Connor? What do the listeners want? Oh, they're hearing this. The listener. The listener. Well, I think I'm curious, you know, and maybe the listener's curious, what is the biggest difference? You mentioned the compile time stuff, but you know, if you're a company or even an individual that's using C++ right now, whether that's 11 or 20, et cetera,
我们要聊吗？你觉得呢，康纳？听众们想听什么？哦，他们正在听这个呢。听众。听众。嗯，我想我很好奇，也许听众也很好奇，最大的区别是什么？你提到了编译时的东西，但是，如果你是一家公司，甚至是目前正在使用 C++（无论是 C++11 还是 20 等）的个人，
you know, what's the pitch or like, you know, the things that current C++ developers might be interested in switching some personal project, or even if they're at a company to use Circle, what's the Delta, like what makes up the delta that would cause people to make that decision? Well, I'm really bleeding edge. So I'm like at 23 or 26. So as soon as there's a proposal that I think is interesting, I put it in. The universal template parameters, that missed the 23 window, but it's been in Circle for like a year and a half already. I think really the delta is that if there's a feature that a company needs to put in, they're likely unable to do that with Clang, but they're likely
你知道的，有什么卖点，或者说，现有的 C++ 开发者可能会对将某些个人项目切换到 Circle 感兴趣的地方，或者如果他们是一家公司，是什么导致人们做出这种决定的“增量”（delta）是什么？好吧，我真的是走在最前沿的。所以我相当于处在 C++23 或 26。因此，一旦有一个我认为有趣的提案，我就把它加进去。通用模板参数，虽然错过了 C++23 的窗口，但在 Circle 里已经存在一年半了。我认为真正的增量在于，如果一家公司需要引入某个特性，他们可能无法用 Clang 做到这一点，但他们很可能
able to do that with Circle. And I think really the idea is it's, I don't mind taking on special functionality and integrating that into the core of the language. I think that's good. And there's this kind of truism, which I think is not right, which is that, you know, what did they say? At the center of C++, there's a simpler language waiting to get out, something like that. Or a smaller language. I don't think a small language is a simpler or a more streamlined developer experience. And I think that getting first-class language features, which Circle as a code base is really tuned to deliver, I think that's super valuable.
可以用 Circle 做到这一点。而且我觉得真正的想法是，我不介意引入特殊的功用并将其实现到语言核心中。我认为这挺好的。而且有一种陈词滥调，我认为是不对的，那就是——他们是怎么说的？在 C++ 的中心，有一个更简单的语言正等待被释放出来，诸如此类。或者说一个更小的语言。我不认为一门小语言就是一门更简单或更精简的开发者体验。我认为获得第一类（first-class）语言特性——Circle 作为代码库正是为了提供这些而进行了高度优化——我认为这超级有价值。
And the idea that we're going to pare down a complex language that has 40 years of history or 50 years of history, and somehow that makes it more responsive to user needs. I don't really believe that. So yeah, I think really it's about trying to anticipate where the kind of work that users want...
那种认为我们要削减一门拥有 40 年或 50 年历史的复杂语言，就能让它更迎合用户需求的观点，我并不怎么相信。所以，是的，我认为这实际上是关于试图预判用户想要的那种工作……
I'm sorry. Her mom is in Virginia today. She just doesn't behave as well for me. I'm the fun parent, not the disciplinarian. Yeah, so I'm just... I'm looking for... I guess I'm still looking for that killer feature.
抱歉。她妈妈今天在弗吉尼亚。她在我面前就没那么听话。我是那个好玩的家长，而不是管教人的那个。所以，我只是……我在寻找……我想我仍在寻找那个杀手级特性。
I think I might have found it recently. But I'm just exploring the language design space. What's the killer feature? Is it the language tuple stuff? No, language tuples are a mess. Nice, but we can get into it. Okay, so another question. Is Circle the most Is Circle the most up-to-date with the standard C++ compiler these days? If you want to try out the latest C++ 23.26 features.
我想我最近可能找到了。但我只是在探索语言设计的空间。什么是杀手级特性？是语言元组（tuple）那套东西吗？不，语言元组是一团糟。挺好，但我们可以深入探讨一下。好的，另一个问题。Circle 是当今与标准 C++ 编译器保持最同步的编译器吗？如果你想尝试最新的 C++23、26 特性的话。
It's hard to say. A lot of it is kind of gated by what's in the standard library. I mean, because what else is using these features? It's possible. I don't know. It's... I'm not even sure what's going in 23, honestly. I'm not even sure what's going in 23.
很难说。这很大程度上取决于标准库里有什么。我的意思是，因为还有什么在用这些特性？有可能。我不知道。这……老实说，我甚至不确定 C++23 里到底有什么。我甚至不确定 C++23 里到底有什么。
I try to keep it very up-to-date, but it's really like... It matters if there's a usage of a feature in a test case in the libc++ test suite. So, as far as standardized features. Okay, so I want to go back to,
我尽量让它保持最新，但实际上这取决于……关键在于 libc++ 测试套件中的测试用例里是否使用了某个特性。所以，就标准化特性而言，就是这样。好吧，我想回到……
you said you found the killer feature. What is it? Well, I think we maybe want to pivot to successor language. Okay, all right, all right, all right. That's kind of what I'm thinking about. So, we will get to the topic that Connor wanted me to discuss with him last week. What do you think of CPP, Frank? Also, wait. Should we, before we get the answer, let's just enumerate off the top.
你刚才说你找到了杀手级特性。那是什么？嗯，我们或许想转到继承者语言的话题上。好吧，好吧，好吧，好吧。这正是我的想法。所以，我们会讨论上周康纳想让我跟他讨论的话题。你对 CPP Front 有何看法？还有，等等。在我们得到答案之前，让我们先列举一下。
If you're a C++ dev and you've been following for like the last year or two, what are all... I mean, Rust has been around for a decade, so that doesn't really count. And Rust is not aimed at being really like a c++ killer it just operates in the same space with different you know safety etc but there is now carbon obviously google announced in july cpp front aka c++2 aka whatever else you want to call it got announced in the closing keynote at CppCon maybe not a great naming strategy to give you two names I've seen it referred to as both Cpp2
如果你是一个 C++ 开发者，并且在过去一两年里一直在关注，都有哪些……我的意思是，Rust 已经存在十年了，所以那不算数。而且 Rust 的目标并不是真正成为 C++ 的杀手，它只是在相同的领域中运作，但有不同的安全机制等。但现在显然有了 Carbon，谷歌在 7 月份宣布了 CPP Front，又名 Cpp2，或者你想叫它别的什么名字，在 CppCon 的闭幕主旨演讲中发布了。也许起两个名字并不是一个很好的命名策略，我见它被称为 Cpp2
and CppFront you mentioned JACT which is the language that exists within Andreas Kling's Serenio OS. Val is a language out of Adobe by Dave Abrahams and friends, formerly who worked on Swift. Is there any other languages or even, Sean, if you want to, you know, because apparently you've been watching from the... Right. So, I mean, carbon is obviously the biggest,
和 CppFront。你提到了 JACT，这是存在于安德烈亚斯·克林（Andreas Kling）的 SerenityOS 中的一门语言。Val 是阿多比（Adobe）的戴夫·亚伯拉罕（Dave Abrahams）及其朋友们推出的一门语言，他们曾参与过 Swift 的开发。还有其他语言吗？或者肖恩，如果你想的话，（因为显然你一直在从旁观察……）没错。我的意思是，Carbon 显然是最宏大、最雄心勃勃的尝试。而且它是背后有真正资源支持的语言。是的。而且我觉得很有趣的是，当他们宣布 Carbon 时，他们说：如果你正在启动一个全新项目，并且没有任何 C++ 依赖，那就用 Rust 编写。如果你是在扩展一个 C++ 项目，你知道的，几年后你可以用 Carbon。但是 Carbon 的解释器没有任何依赖项，是用 C++ 编写的。所以我很好奇，那些说你需要用 Rust 编写一切的人，到底什么时候才会真正开始用 Rust 编写一切？因为我们还没到那个阶段。我其实觉得——所以我在关于 Carbon 的各种演讲中听到过好几次这个观点。我认为
most ambitious attempt. And it's the one with the real resources behind it. Yeah. And I think it's interesting that when they announced carbon, they said, if you're starting a greenfield project and you don't have any C++ dependencies, write it in Rust. If you're extending a C++ project, you know, in a couple years you can do it in Carbon. But Carbon, the interpreter, which has no
它之所以这样表述，可能是因为 Carbon 背后的家伙们不想暗示他们正试图取代 Rust，或者该语言目前的形式（非常实验性）是诸如
dependencies, is written in C++. So I'm wondering at what point, like, people who say you need to write everything in Rust will actually start writing everything in Rust. Because we're not at that point yet. I actually think, so I've seen this talking point come up a few times in various talks about Carbon. And I think that
Rust 之类语言的替代品。他们不想显得自大。但我怀疑许多致力于 Carbon 的人希望构建一门这样的语言：是的，它对这种“与遗留代码合作”的机会很有用。但我认为他们也只是想构建一门优秀的语言，也许在未来的某个时候，这门语言将好到足以用于新项目。不过我要问的是，为什么不直接用 Rust 编写呢？是的，但我想是因为他们是 C++ 圈子的人。可能因为他们是建立在 LLVM 库之上的。它不是建立在 LLVM 之上的。哦，你是说解释器？是的。我不知道。
it's perhaps phrased that way because the folks behind Carbon don't want to suggest that they're trying to replace Rust or that the language in its current form, which is very experimental, is a substitute for something
你说的有道理。你说的有道理。但如果你把一群 C++ 人聚在一个房间里，他们可能会尽量去使用 C++。但他们明确地在写一个受 Rust 启发的替代品，因为他们说 Rust 更好。我知道，我知道。那你就用 Rust 嘛。所以，说什么 C++……这是一个好观点。说什么 C++……我确实知道，而且我觉得提一下这个也无妨：
like Rust. They don't want to be presumptuous. But I suspect that a lot of people who are working on Carbon hope to build a language that is, you know, yes, good for this, you know, working with legacy code opportunity. But I think they also just want to build a good language that maybe at some point in the future, that language would be a language that would be good enough to use for new projects. I'm asking, though, why not write
他们曾一度考虑用 Swift 编写解释器。他们曾考虑用 Swift 编写解释器？我应该知道这个的，因为我和康纳对这些需求了解有一阵子了。
it in Rust? Yeah, but I think because they're C++ folks. Probably because they're building on top of the LLVM libraries. It's not on top of LLVM. Oh, you mean like the interpreter? Yeah. I don't know.
我们其实只是旁观者，我认为——我甚至觉得最初在 Swift 中有过一些工作，我也可能完全搞错了。所以，如果有人比我们更多地参与其中，并觉得“根本不是那回事”，请随时在 Twitter 上回复我。但我认为可能在 Swift 中做过一些最初的工作，但后来因为互操作性或其他原因，基本上他们最后说，目前用 C++ 编写会更容易。如果我们将来想做点别的，也许我们会考虑。但我认为他们确实，你知道的，这并没有回答：
You make a good point. You make a good point. But you put a bunch of C++ people in the room, they're going to probably try to use C++. But they're explicitly writing a Rust-inspired alternative because they say Rust is better. I know, I know. So use Rust then. Like, what is this about saying C++? This is a good point. what is this about C++ I do know and I think it's okay to mention this that
如果 Rust 更好，为什么不用 Rust？但他们确实曾一度考虑使用不同的语言。是的，有道理。所以 Carbon 的信条，我的意思是，有点让人难以接受。首先，按设计它没有函数重载。我认为 C++ 本质上就是带有重载的 C。这可以说是这门语言的核心。它没有异常处理。
at one point they were considering writing the interpreter in Swift they were considering writing the interpreter in Swift? I should know this because Connor and I have been read in on the requirements for a while
很多人不喜欢异常处理，但另一方面，如果你的 C++ 代码可能会抛出异常，你将不得不使用另一种理解异常的语言来支持这一点。这一点，我并不是完全……我认为 Carbon 实验的这部分可能没有被深思熟虑过。会变得更好。它被思考过了，当然。没有多重继承。现在，你可能不在乎这一点，但我经常使用它。Circle 编译器中的一切，所有的实体都是通过多重继承的“is-a”（是一种）关系来表达的。这只是我经常使用的东西，而且我认为很多编译器开发者都真正依赖这个特性。而且它没有运行时开销。它只是一种组织类的方式。目前，这里没有原始指针或真实指针的概念。我认为这必须要改变，因为当你与系统代码交互时，系统会把指针还给你，
we just were observers really and i think i think there was like even an initial work in swift i could be totally wrong so like if you know there's people that are more involved in this and they're like that's not at all the case then feel free to respond on twitter but i think there may have been some initial work in Swift, but then because of the interop or something, there was some reason that basically they ended up saying that this is just going to be easier to write it in C++ for now. If we want in the future, do something else, maybe we consider that. But I think they actually did, you know, that doesn't answer,
你将不得不处理指针算术以及所有这些。头文件中有大量的表面积为了很好的理由而包含指针。而且它没有构造函数。我想它没有构造函数是因为它没有异常处理。那么，如何从构造函数中返回一个错误呢？好吧，你必须做一个工厂函数，一个静态成员函数，而它必须返回一个对端（pair），
why not Rust if Rust is better? But they did consider using a different language at one point. Yeah, fair enough. So the tenets of Carbon, I mean, they're kind of tough to swallow. So first of all, there's no function overloading by design. And I think C++ is really C with overloading. That's kind of the core of the language. There's no exception handling.
比如一个带有错误代码或已构造对象的变体（variant）。从这个意义上说，它有点像 Rust，但目前没有构造函数。所以没有子对象条件化操作符（sub-object conditionalizers），至少在传统意义上是没有的。所以问题是：它将如何与 C++ 无缝互操作？我的意思是，这是关于 Carbon 的一个重大、开放的问题。
A lot of people don't like exception handling, but on the other hand, if your C++ code is potentially throwing, you're going to have to have another language that understands exceptions to be able to support that. That part, I don't fully... I think that perhaps that part of the carbon experiment has not been well it gets better it gets thought about sure uh there's no multiple inheritance now you may not care about that but i use it constantly everything in the circle compiler all the entities are expressed through is a relationships with multiple inheritance it's just something i use a lot and i think a lot of compiler people do it, really rely on that feature. And it's got no runtime penalty. It's just a way to organize classes. Right now, there's no sense of raw
你知道的，Carbon 真正比竞争对手具备优势的地方在于 C++ 的互操作。但这也是——这不是今天就有原型的东西。从某些方面来说，这不是 Carbon 最成熟的部分。好吧，我可不这么认为。我认为 Carbon——我对 Carbon 的解读是，它是被转变成一门语言的谷歌 C++ 风格指南。谷歌的风格指南规定没有异常。
pointers or real pointers. I think that's going to have to change, because when you interact with system code that's going to give you back pointers, you're going to have to change because when you interact with system code, that's going to give you back pointers. You're going to have to deal with pointer arithmetic and all of that. There's a lot of surface area in header files that have pointers for good reasons. And there's no constructors. And I think there's no constructors because there's no exception handling. So how do you return an error out of a constructor? Well, you have to make a factory function, a static member function, and that's going to have to return a pair,
它说没有多重继承。就像风格指南中规定不要做的很多事情，在 Carbon 中都没有。所以他们在与根据该指南编写的谷歌内部项目进行互操作时，可能会比外部用户拥有更好的体验。从这个意义上说，它可能不是 C++ 的继承者。它可能只是“谷歌内部 C++”的继承者。
like a variant with their error code or the constructed object. So in that sense, it's like Rust, but there are no constructors right now. So there's no sub-object conditionalizers, at least in the conventional sense. So the question is like, how is it going to seamlessly interoperate with C++? And I mean, that is the big, you know,
好吧，我要反驳这一点。我认为 Carbon 背后的家伙们，他们认识到作为一个由谷歌员工发起、最初作为谷歌内部项目启动的项目，他们深知像 Carbon 这样的项目要取得成功，不能仅仅局限于谷歌内部，这一点有多重要。为什么？因为我认为原因有几个。
open question with Carbon. You know, the thing that, the place where Carbon offers true advantage over its competitors is the C++ interop. But that is also – that's not something that there's a prototype of today. And in some ways that is – it's not the most mature part of Carbon. Well, I don't know about that. I think Carbon, my reading of Carbon is that it's the Google C++ style guide turned into a language. And the Google style guide says no exceptions.
第一，如果你只有一个主要组织投资于某样东西，并且只有一个主要组织对某样东西拥有所有权，它就会变得非常量身定制，以适应那个组织的需求和用途。这会对其成长上限造成限制。但我们谈论的是谷歌。我的意思是，它本身就像是一个国家。是的，但他们明确不希望它成为一个纯粹的谷歌项目。他们不希望它被视为一个纯粹的谷歌项目。而且它确实不是。诚然，许多核心合作者都是谷歌员工，
It says like no multiple inheritance. Like a lot of the things the style guide says not to do are things that are not in Carbon. So they may have a better experience interoperating with Google internal projects that are written according to that guy than outside users would have. So in that sense, maybe it's not a C++ successor. Maybe it's a C++ at Google successor.
但他们为了建立一个更广泛的社区付出了巨大的努力。我会这么说：我看到 Carbon 具有最大潜力的方面在于它的治理模式、背后的团队以及他们的目标。所以我赞同这门编程语言的目标。而且我认为，比一门特定的编程语言今天处于什么位置更重要的，对我和而言，是这门编程语言是如何被管理以及它是如何演进的。我对他们建立的演进过程及其随时间解决这些问题的能力非常有信心。我认为如果 Carbon 成功了，当它在三四年或五年后开始走向成功时，Carbon 的面貌将会与今天的形态大不相同。
Well, I'll push back on that. I think that the folks behind Carbon, I think they recognize that as a project that was started by people at Google that started originally as an internal Google project, they understand how important it is for something like Carbon to be successful, for it to not just solely be a Google thing. Why? Because I think it is a few reasons.
我只是根据当前的设计文档在说。但我认为他们为成功做好了准备，并且建立了良好的机制，让他们能够把今天的 Carbon 的外貌演进为适合他们心目中的受众、并实现他们心目中的目标的东西。好的。那么另一方面，我的意思是，我列举了 Carbon 移除的所有那些 C++ 用户期望拥有的东西，比如函数重载。是的。但他们——我的意思是，他们希望提供良好的用户体验。
One, if you only have one major organization investing in a thing and only one major organization having ownership over a thing, it becomes very tailored to that organization's needs and uses. And that puts like a cap on how far it can grow. But we're talking about Google. I mean, it's a country unto itself. Yeah, but like they specifically don't want it to be a Google-only project. They don't want it to be perceived as a Google-only project. And it's not. It is admittedly true that many of the core collaborators are folks at Google,
所以他们在添加什么？其中许多都是受 Rust 启发的东西。比如不用函数重载，而是基于概念的重载（concept-based overloading），或者他们所说的 Rust 特性（traits），在 Swift 中则是协议（protocols）。而在 2011 年之前的 C++ 中，它们就是概念（concepts）。你知道的，他们在这些接口或特性上投入了大量的资金。另一件事是，他们的一些类型具有选择类型（choice type），这就像 Rust 的枚举（enum），并且他们有第一类的元组（tuple）。因此，当 Carbon 宣布时，你知道的，我想：是什么让开发者对这个感到兴奋？似乎就是这套新特性。
but they've gone to great lengths to build a wider community. And I'll say this, the thing that I see the greatest potential in in Carbon is its governance model and the people behind it and their goals. So I agree with the goals that the programming language has. And I think that more important than where a particular programming language is today, to me, is how that programming language is managed and how it evolves. And I have a great deal of confidence in the evolution process that they've set up and in its ability to address these problems over time. I think if Carbon is successful, what Carbon will look like in three to four to five years when it starts to become successful will be very different from the shape that it is today.
但所有这些都可以在 C++ 中实现。尤其是像和类型（sum type）这样语言级别的变体（variant）。这真的非常简单。它只是一个带有某些由编译器生成的构造函数和赋值运算符的标签联合体（tagged union）。所以我很早就实现了这一点，在 Carbon 宣布之后不久。我实现了 Rust 的问号运算符，也就是传播（propagation），所以如果你有一个名为 result 的选择类型，它有一个 ok 字段和一个 error 字段，你可以使用逗号运算符。而在运行时，它会检查选择类型的活动元素，并要么产出 ok 元素，要么返回 error。
I'm just going on to what the current design docs say. But I think that they have set themselves up for success and that they have put good institutions in place to allow them to evolve what carbon looks like today to something that works for the audience that they have in mind and achieves those goals that they have in mind. Okay. So on the flip side, I mean, I enumerated all these things that carbon removes that C++ users expect to have, like function overloads. Yeah. But they, I mean, they want it to be a good user experience.
这是一种在没有异常的情况下传播错误的方法。当你使用这些工厂函数时，这就是你所需要的。既然没有构造函数，工厂函数就会返回一个该类型的 result，后面加上逗号以及任何错误代码。然后你就可以使用逗号运算符来链式传播，而无需写一堆繁琐的代码，从而实现一种静态异常处理。这里有第一类语言元组的语法。所以它就像是逗号分隔的类型列表，或者逗号分隔的表达式列表。最后，还有概念，或者 Carbon 称之为接口的东西。所以不要把它和 C++ 概念混淆了。所以我回溯到了 2007、2008 年的档案，翻出了旧的 C++0X 概念措辞。那是大约 100 页的措辞，道格·雷格（Doug Gregor），主要是道格·雷格写的。当时有——有印第安纳学派，还有德克萨斯学派，德克萨斯大学什么的。是的。
So what are the things they're adding? And a lot of these are Rust-inspired things. Like instead of function overloading, there's like concept-based overloading, or what they call like Rust traits, or in Swift, they're protocols. And in C++ prior to 2011 they were concepts. You know they're putting a lot of investment in these interfaces or these traits. The other thing is some types they have have a choice type, which is just like the Rust enum, and they have a first class tuple. And so when Carbon was announced, you know, I thought like, you know, what is getting the developers excited about this? And it seems to be this new set of features.
那么他们都在添加什么内容呢？其中很多都是受 Rust 启发的特性。比如，函数重载被替换成了基于概念的重载，或者他们所说的 Rust 特性（traits），在 Swift 中它们叫协议（protocols）。在 2011 年之前的 C++ 中，它们被称为概念（concepts）。你知道的，他们在这些接口或特性上投入了大量的精力。另一件事是，他们有些类型具备选择类型（choice type），这就像 Rust 的枚举（enum），而且他们还有一等公民的元组（tuple）。所以当 Carbon 宣布的时候，你知道的，我在想，究竟是什么让开发者对这个感到兴奋呢？看来就是这套新特性。
But all of these things can be implemented in C++. Especially something like a sum type, a language-level variant. It's really easy. It's just another data type. It's just a tagged union with some compiler-generated constructors and assignment operators. So I implemented that pretty early on, after the carbon announcement. I implemented the question mark operator from Rust, which is the propagation, so that if you have a choice type called result and has an okay field and an error field, you can use the comma operator. And at runtime, it'll examine the active element of the choice type, and it'll either yield the okay element or it'll return
但所有这些东西都可以在 C++ 中实现。特别是像和类型（sum type）这种语言级别的变体（variant），其实非常简单。它只是另一种数据类型，带有一些编译器生成的构造函数和赋值运算符的标记联合体（tagged union）。所以在 Carbon 宣布后不久，我就很早就实现了这一点。我实现了 Rust 中的问号运算符，也就是错误传播机制，这样如果你有一个名为 result 的选择类型，它包含一个 okay 字段和一个 error field，你就可以使用逗号运算符。在运行时，它会检查选择类型的活动元素，并产出 okay 元素或者返回
the error. And this is a way to propagate errors without exceptions. And this is what you need when you're using these factory functions. Since you don't have constructors, a factory function would return a result of that type, comma, whatever the error code is. And then you would be able to use the comma operator to chain the propagation and without a whole bunch of typing, have a kind of static exception handling. There's syntax for first-class language tuples. So it's just like comma separated list of types
错误。这是一种在没有异常的情况下传播错误的方法。这正是你在使用这些工厂函数时所需要的。既然你没有构造函数，工厂函数就会返回该类型的结果（result）、逗号以及任何错误代码。然后你就可以使用逗号运算符来链式传播错误，而无需大量的类型声明，从而实现一种静态异常处理。这里有一等公民语言元组的语法。所以它就像是逗号分隔的类型列表
or comma separated list of expressions. And then finally, there's concepts or what Carbon is calling interfaces. So it's not to confuse them with C++ concepts. So I went back to the archives to like 2007, 2008, and I dug up the old C++ OX concept wording. It's like 100 pages of wording, Doug Rager, mostly Doug Rager. And there was like, there's the Indiana school and there's the Texas, University of Texas, I guess. Yeah.
或者逗号分隔的表达式列表。最后，是概念或者 Carbon 所称的接口（interfaces）。这样就不会把它们与 C++ 的概念混淆了。所以我翻看了 2007 年、2008 年左右的旧文档，找出了旧的 C++ 0X 概念措辞。大约有 100 页的措辞，Doug Rager 写的，主要是 Doug Rager。当时还有印第安纳学派和德克萨斯学派，也就是德克萨斯大学，我猜。是的。
Right. And there was kind of a, after a few years of back and forth, they had a kind of a joint proposal for this. And it was merged into the language. And then I think in 2009, it was all removed. And then we went without exceptions until C++ 20, and then they were without concepts rather. And then concepts we got were concepts light, which are basically just porcelain around enable if. So it's really kind of gutted the feature. But that concept
对。而且经过几年时间的反复拉锯，他们针对这个提出了一种联合提案。它被合并到了语言中。然后我认为在2009年，这些全都被删除了。接着我们就这样一直没有异常（exceptions），直到C++ 20，不过它们其实是没有概念（concepts）。然后我们得到的概念是“轻量级概念”（concepts light），这基本上只是 enable_if 外面的一层瓷釉。所以这实际上有点像掏空了这个特性。但那个概念
feature from 2006 is exactly what Carbon is staking really its entire core on, which is how do we do overloading and how do we do generics? And for them, they said, we want to have these C++ OX concepts. They use the term interface to keep it distinct from what concepts are in C++ now. So I've been implementing that and it's been like really difficult. But I think collectively, I have more confidence that these are the features that users want to see because these are the users that, these are the features that persuaded Google management to be able to, you know, say, we want to fund this experiment and see where this experiment goes. And you talk to a lot of other
2006年的那个特性，恰恰是 Carbon 的整个核心所押注的对象，也就是我们如何做重载以及我们如何做泛型？对他们来说，他们表示，我们想要这些 C++ OX 概念。他们使用“接口”（interface）这个术语，来把它和现在 C++ 中的概念区分开来。所以我一直在实现这个，而且这真的非常困难。但我觉得总的来说，我更有信心，这些是用户希望看到的特性，因为这些用户是……这些特性说服了 Google 管理层，让他们能够，你知道的，说，我们想要资助这个实验，看看这个实验能走向何方。而你跟许多其他
kind of C++ old timers and they, they are really like Dave Abraham at CPP Now. He was still agitated and angry about the removal of concepts back in 2009. There was this large schism you know it's possible that uh you know the folks like doug gregor and dave abrahams who went off to create swift would have still been working on c++ yeah i think i think this was a a major defeat as far as like losing um you know senior senior leadership. Yeah. Yeah, and I think for some of this stuff, we have to like... I think the committee process has been not optimal for C++
那种 C++ 老一辈的人交流，他们真的……比如在 CPP Now 上的 Dave Abrahams。他对于 2000 年代末移除概念这件事，依然感到激动和愤怒。当时存在着巨大的分裂，你知道的，可能……像 Doug Gregor 和 Dave Abrahams 这样去创建了 Swift 的人们，本来可能还在继续致力于 C++ 呢。是的，我认为，我认为这是一个重大的失败，就失去……你知道的，资深、资深领导层而言。对。是的，而且我认为对于其中某些东西，我们必须……我认为委员会的流程对 C++ 来说一直不是最优的
because people really... People really go to the mat. At the beginning of the episode, the cold open. I think a lot of the voters, they go to the mat about what... If they like a feature or not. They think it's a good feature. And that's important, but that's not the only concern.
因为人们真的……人们真的会为之全力以赴。在剧集开头，也就是冷开场时。我认为很多投票者，他们会为了某个东西……如果他们喜欢某个特性与否，而全力以赴。他们认为这是一个好特性。这很重要，但这并不是唯一的关切。
I think keeping the community together is another concern. And that's something I've learned writing a compiler. A lot of the features I implement are not things I care about particularly. Like these generics I'm putting in, I don't really care about C++ OX concepts or Rust traits. But I know that a lot of other people really care about them. I mean, they really care about them. And I'll believe them in that and I'll put the effort in to make that happen. And I think it's kind of important that we give other people who've over time proven themselves to be thoughtful, capable people,
我认为保持社区凝聚力是另一个关切。这也是我在编写编译器时学到的东西。我实现的许多特性并不是我特别关心的东西。就像我正在加入的这些泛型，我其实并不怎么关心 C++ OX 概念或 Rust 特 trait。但我知道有很多人非常关心它们。我是说，他们真的很关心。我相信他们的判断，并且我会投入精力去实现它。而且我认为这相当重要，我们应该给予那些随着时间证明了自己是深思熟虑、有能力的人
we need to give them the benefit of the doubt and say, if they're really interested in these features, we should put that into language, even if I'm not personally into it. Because otherwise, it prevents the language from moving forward. We're never going to get 100% agreement on really anything. So I think we need to kind of like give ourselves, you know, more of a benefit of the doubt when it comes to adopting features. The language won't evolve otherwise. In doing your historical deep dive,
我们应该给予他们信任（benefit of the doubt），并表示，如果他们真的对这些特性感兴趣，我们就应该把它们放进语言里，即使我个人并不太感兴趣。因为否则的话，它会阻碍语言向前发展。对于任何真正的事情，我们永远不可能达成 100% 的一致。所以我认为，在采纳特性这方面，我们确实需要……你知道的，多给予彼此一些信任。否则语言是不会进化的。在进行你的历史深度挖掘时，
was it documented why they ended up getting rid of them? Obviously there was folks on the committee that obviously weren't a fan of it. What was the justification? Buddy, you're going to have to... that's a whole another episode where we get we get some people from that time period on to talk well i mean i i was curious
官方是否有记录说明他们最终为什么要废弃它们？显然委员会里有些人显然不是它的粉丝。那时的理由是什么？老兄，你得……那是另一整期节目了，我们需要把那个时期的某些人请来聊聊。好吧，我的意思是，我也很好奇
too just from a technical standpoint because like the wording they have isn't i mean it's it's okay it doesn't answer all my questions and there's really nobody to go and ask anymore because we're talking about language that's 15 years old. I think there was an issue, a disagreement, between like Bjarne's camp that wanted implicit concept maps so that if a type is probed and this type is determined to satisfy the requirements of the interface, then it satisfies the interface as opposed to explicit concept map.
仅仅从技术角度来看，因为他们提供的措辞并不是——我的意思是，还行吧——它并没有回答我所有的问题，而且真的没有人可以去问了，因为我们谈论的是一门有 15 年历史的语言。我认为当时存在一个问题、一个分歧，介于贾恩（Bjarne）阵营和其它阵营之间，贾恩想要隐式概念映射（implicit concept maps），这样如果对一个类型进行探测，并且确定该类型满足接口的要求，那么它就满足该接口，这与显式概念映射相对。
It's just like a choice of defaults. And I think there were a lot of those. And then the time was running out to get something into 11. And at the end, instead of getting consensus on what the default should be, the rest of the C++ committee members just decided to remove the feature. They're like, well, the clock's running down. We don't want to ship something that we don't have consensus on. So they removed the feature, and then they never really got back to work on it.
这就像是对默认值的选择。而且我认为这类事情有很多。当时把东西塞进 C++11 的时间已经快用完了。最后，C++ 委员会的其余成员没有就默认值应该是什么达成共识，而是直接决定移除这个特性。他们觉得，好吧，时间不多了。我们不想推出一个没有共识的东西。所以他们移除了这个特性，然后就再也没有真正重新开始研究它。
At that point, they just moved on. I mean, I'm sure there's a lot of interpersonal conflicts. conflicts? I think there were but it was a combination of a variety of technical disagreements and then those led to a variety of interpersonal arguments and I think it reached a point
在那之后，他们就直接前进了。我的意思是，我确信这其中有很多个人之间的冲突。冲突？我想是有的，但这结合了各种技术分歧，然后这些分歧又导致了各种人际争论，而且我认为它达到了一个点
where both camps became very entrenched and there wasn't really a compromise to be found. I tend to not particularly like the design of the concepts that we got. that the OX concepts design was much more natural and much more how I would imagine. Like when I write up in like comments, like what a concept should look like, it's much, you know, like I define sort of like the, you know, the archetype of what it would look like.
两个阵营都变得非常顽固，而且根本找不到妥协的余地。我倾向于并不是特别喜欢我们最终得到的概念的设计。OX 概念的设计要自然得多，也更符合我的想象。比如当我写注释时，比如一个概念应该长什么样，它要……你知道的，就像我定义了它会是什么样子的原型一样。
And that's much more what the C++OX concepts look like. Whereas with the concepts that we have, you have to write out these examples of how it'll be used. And I just find that supremely weird. Well, the concepts we have now don't do type checking at definition. That's the big difference. Like, Rust traits and what they're trying
那更接近 C++OX 概念的样子。而对于我们拥有的现有概念，你必须写出它将如何被使用的这些示例。我只是觉得这极其诡异。嗯，我们现在拥有的概念在定义时不做类型检查。这就是巨大的区别。比如，Rust 的 trait 以及他们正试图
to put into Carbon, which they're calling Interface, and the Swift protocols, which is actually separate compilation and there's a runtime penalty for using the generics in Swift, but the general form is the same. That type checking is done at definition. So you write your function generic and each of the
放进 Carbon 中的东西（他们称之为接口），以及 Swift 的协议（实际上是单独编译的，在 Swift 中使用泛型会有运行时惩罚，但大致形式是相同的）。那种类型检查是在定义时完成的。所以你编写你的泛型函数，并且每一个
template parameters, the generic parameters subscribes to some number of interfaces. So it says like, this is an input iterator and that input iterator has a bunch of refinements indicating, you know, it's regular, it can be copied this way, and it has these operations. And only those operations that are parts of the interfaces for each of the data types can be used inside that function. If you use any other thing, then you get an error at definition. Yeah. In C++20 concepts, the concepts are just an enable if check. So if you get past that function declaration into the body, the concepts at that point are moot. They're
模板参数、泛型参数都遵循一定数量的接口。所以它会说，这是一个输入迭代器（input iterator），并且该输入迭代器有一堆限定条件，表明（你知道的）它是常规的，它可以这样被复制，并且它具有这些操作。只有那些作为各个数据类型接口一部分的操作，才能在该函数内部使用。如果你使用任何其他东西，那么你在定义时就会得到一个错误。是的。在 C++20 概念中，概念仅仅是一个 enable_if 检查。所以如果你通过了那个函数声明进入函数体，那么到那个点上概念就已经无关紧要了。它们
not operative anymore. I think the question of whether we could do type checking with OX concepts, that was really sort of what killed it, was that they um that it would become impractical or computationally impractical or something to that effect um or the or it would be too complex um but then we ended up with this concepts light and without and you certainly can't do type checking in that model um but without that what's really the value of concepts? Like it doesn't really seem to me like it delivers anything more than a smarter enable if. It was promised that it was going to give us
不再起作用了。我认为我们是否可以用 OX 概念进行类型检查这个问题，那才是真正杀死它的原因，是因为它们……呃，这会变得不切实际、或者在计算上不切实际等等诸如此类……或者它会变得过于复杂……但最终我们得到了这个轻量级概念，并且没有……你在这个模型中肯定无法进行类型检查，但如果没有这个，概念的真正价值到底是什么？听起来它似乎并没有带来比更聪明的 enable_if 更多东西。它曾承诺会给我们
these better diagnostics. And I will admit the past like year, the diagnostics have gotten slightly better, but it really does not, I think, substantially enhance the diagnostic experience in the ways that we thought it would. And yeah, I don't really see what the tangible benefits are other than it's a cleaner way to do enable-if. I don't think we have to worry about C++20 concepts
这些更好的诊断信息。我承认在过去的一年里，诊断信息确实稍微好了一点，但它真的没有，我认为，在我们在想象中以为的那样显著增强诊断体验。而且，是的，除了它是做 enable-if 的一种更整洁的方式之外，我真的看不出有什么切实的益处。我认为我们不必担心 C++20 概念
because we have evidence coming from these successor languages. Swift has the protocols. Rust has the traits. And now there's like a decade of usage experience where the customers are more or less satisfied with that, with that kind of contract between the function and the caller. And I think it makes sense now that we have, you know, so much usage knowledge to try to go back and implement that in C++. So what I've been doing is, like, I have archetype establishment, which is when you mark up your function template with all these interfaces, it's the conjunction of these interfaces indicating the capabilities of the types, that is hard to use internally.
因为我们有来自这些后继语言的证据。Swift 有协议。Rust 有 trait。现在大约有十年的使用经验，客户或多或少对这种函数与调用者之间的契约感到满意。而且我认为现在既然我们有了（你知道的）这么多的使用知识，尝试回过头来在 C++ 中实现这一点是有意义的。所以我一直在做的是，我有原型建立（archetype establishment），也就是当你用所有这些接口来标记你的函数模板时，它是表明类型能力的这些接口的合集，这在内部很难使用。
And I think the problem is that if you were to specialize a class template over one of these archetypes, in the current C++ scheme, you can't use any of those member functions because those member functions are only known once that class template is specialized with real types, which is during instantiation. Because you don't know if it's going to hit a partial template specialization, if it's going
而我认为问题在于，如果你要在这些原型之一之上特化一个类模板，在当前的 C++ 方案中，你不能使用任何这些成员函数，因为这些成员函数只有在该类模板用真实类型进行特化后才可知，也就是在实例化（instantiation）期间。因为你不知道它是否会命中偏特化模板特化（partial template specialization），它是否会
to hit an explicit specialization. So I've been going through and creating new kinds of fundamental data types. So I have class generics and choice generics. So if you have a template with the template parameter list class foo, that's the regular class template. But if you have generic with the template argument list class foo, now foo is a class generic. And that has a guarantee that there's no partial or explicit specializations and it allows you to um to see the
命中显式特化。所以我一直在经历并创建新型的基本数据类型。所以我拥有类泛型（class generics）和选择泛型（choice generics）。因此，如果你有一个带有模板参数列表 `class foo` 的模板，那就是常规的类模板。但如果你有一个带有模板参数列表 `class foo` 的 generic，现在 `foo` 就是一个类泛型。这有一个保证，即不存在偏特化或显式特化，它允许你……
uh the the members of that class at definition so i think the problem is that and maybe this was a problem back 15 years ago was that c++ didn't really have the full vocabulary to support um early type checking in a way that was convenient. But I think a lot of the decisions for generics in Rust and Swift, and I'm sure Carbon, when it kind of shakes out, is going to limit partial specialization and explicit specialization to allow you to fully type check the data members of a class that you're using inside a generic function. So I've just got a whole bunch of things
呃，在定义时看到该类的成员，所以我认为问题在于，也许这也是 15 年前的问题，那就是 C++ 真的没有完整的词汇表来以一种方便的方式支持……早期类型检查。但我认为 Rust 和 Swift 中泛型的许多决策，而且我相信 Carbon 在尘埃落定后，也会限制偏特化和显式特化，以允许你对在泛型函数内部使用的一个类的成员数据进行完整的类型检查。所以我刚刚手头上有一大堆事情
in flight now to try to bring the new features that are promised by Carbon into C++ without having any concern about breaking compatibility. It's all embedded in existing C++ compiler. And what's your motivation for doing that?
正在进行中，试图将 Carbon 承诺的新特性引入 C++ 中，而完全不用担心打破兼容性。它们全都嵌入在现有的 C++ 编译器中。你这样做的动机是什么？
My motivation? Well, I'm always looking for features that are going to... That are going to bring you users, yeah. Yeah, that are going to be the hit feature. And I think that... But is your point also that we don't need a successor language because we can make C++ better? I don't think that's my...
我的动机？嗯，我一直在寻找那些能够……能够为你带来用户的特性，是的。是的，能够成为热门特性的特性。而且我认为……但你的观点也是我们不需要后继语言，因为我们可以让 C++ 变得更好？我不认为那是我的……
I mean, that might shake out. I don't know. But it kind of is up to the people who helm those successor languages. Because if these successor languages work really well, then they can speak for themselves. I'm just speaking for my evolution to C++. And I think that C++ gets a lot of flack. But I think we can still evolve it in any direction we want.
我的意思是，事情最后可能会这样发展。我不知道。但这有点取决于那些掌舵这些后继语言的人。因为如果这些后继语言运行得真的很好，那么它们就能不言自明。我只是在为我向 C++ 的演进发声。而且我认为 C++ 受到了很多指责。但我认为我们仍然可以朝着我们想要的任何方向推进它的演进。
If we wanted to put vowel-style value semantics in it, I think we could do that. I think we could evolve it in really almost any direction and still retain core compatibility with all the code out there. Yeah, I tend to agree with you. I think most of the C++ committee and most other implementers don't. Why do you think so few people see the potential for evolving C++? Well, they don't want to have to do 20 years of proposal revisions. For some of these features, they would take
如果我们想把价值语义（value semantics）放进去，我认为我们能做到。我认为我们几乎可以把它向任何方向演进，同时仍然保留与现有所有代码的核心兼容性。是的，我倾向于同意你的看法。我认为大多数 C++ 委员会成员以及大多数其他实现者并不这么认为。为什么你觉得很少有人看到演进 C++ 的潜力？嗯，他们不想去搞 20 年的提案修订。对于其中某些特性，它们需要
forever to get through the committee. And it's easier for one person or a small group. The Google people, who were already the major claim maintainers, could have just forked claim, and they could have built the carbon features straight into claim. And they could call it a successor language.
花无限长的时间才能通过委员会。而且对于一个人或一小群人来说，这更容易。Google 的那些人，他们本来就是主要的 Clang 维护者，本可以简单地 Fork Clang，并且他们本可以将 Carbon 特性直接构建到 Clang 中。他们本可以称之为一个后继语言。
That's fine, but it would have been a super set of C plus plus. Yeah. It could have had a new syntax. They could have, even if they wanted made a context for a new context, free grammar that has not even all the features, but still plugs into the existing compiler.
那没问题，但这将会是 C++ 的一个超集。是的。它本可以有一个新的语法。他们本可以，甚至如果他们愿意的话，可以为一种新的上下文无关文法创造一个上下文，它甚至不包含所有特性，但仍然可以接入现有的编译器中。
Yeah. Right. Now I think that's just a different workflow, but it's one where at all points you can keep compiling a C++ hello world and you know it's going to work all the way through and you can make your incremental changes and you can evolve
对。现在我认为这只是一种不同的工作流程，但它是一个在任何时候你都可以继续编译 C++ "Hello World" 的流程，并且你知道它会一直正常工作，你可以进行渐进式的修改，并且你可以将它
it in any direction and I think you know that's what I'm doing and having a really nimble C++ compiler source base you know allows me to do that and I think that's really the value. But you also don't have a committee of 300 people that you have to get to sign off on. But the clang maintainers don't have to do that either.
向任何方向演进，而且我认为（你知道的）这就是我正在做的，拥有一个非常敏捷的 C++ 编译器代码库（你知道的）允许我这样做，我认为这才是真正的价值。但你也没有一个必须获得签字批准的 300 人委员会。但 Clang 维护者也不必非得那样做。
They could have just said, we're going to fork Carbon. And Carbon is going to be basically clang with these other features. They didn't do that. Why don't they? Well, I don't know. I mean, they have a different strategy. I mean, they think differently of C++ than I think of it. Right, because I think they would argue that's not C++, that's C++ with extensions.
他们本可以说，我们要 Fork Carbon。Carbon 基本上就会是带有这些其他特性的 Clang。他们没有那样做。他们为什么不呢？嗯，我不知道。我的意思是，他们有不同的策略。我的意思是，他们对 C++ 的看法与我对它的看法不同。对，因为我认为他们会争辩说那不是 C++，那是带有扩展的 C++。
Well, okay. What's the difference, though? At what point does the circle dialect of C++ become its own language? This is – I don't think this is a – this is just a vocabulary distinction. I don't think it has any – it doesn't affect anything. What matters is if you're a company and you've got billions of dollars of value in C++ source spaces, you want to keep compiling that. You want to make sure that every year you get the new version out of the new build out. And it'd be great if the compiler improves with your own software. And we can do
好吧，好吧。不过，区别在哪里？在哪个点上，Circle 语言的 C++ 方言会变成它自己的语言？这——我不认为这是一个——这只是一种词汇上的区别。我认为它没有任何——它不影响任何事情。重要的是，如果你是一家公司，并且你在 C++ 代码库中拥有数十亿美元的价值，你会想要继续编译它。你会希望确保每年都能从新构建中获得新版本。如果编译器能随着你自己的软件一起改进，那就太棒了，而且我们可以做到
that. We can evolve C++ much more quickly and actually give users the features they want without having to break anything. Or if you do break, it could be a tiny small break.
这一点。我们可以更快地演进 C++，并且真正赋予用户他们想要的特性，而无需破坏任何东西。或者如果你确实破坏了，它也可以是一个极其微小的破坏。
I've gotten a lot more bold about my extensions recently. I've realized I have this pragma, like pound pragma feature and feature name. So I have one like pound pragma feature generics, pound pragma feature tuple, a couple others. And what they do is they draw new tokens, but only for the file. So I can pound pragma feature generics and then include any STL header. And I know it won't conflict with those new tokens I brought in because the token scope is only in that file and I can turn it off if I want. And now I realize, well, why not just like, you know, evolve really rapidly.
我最近对我的扩展变得更大胆了。我意识到我有这个 pragma，比如 `#pragma feature` 和特性名称。所以我有一个像 `#pragma feature generics`、`#pragma feature tuple`，还有其他几个。它们的作用是引入新的 Token，但仅限于该文件。所以我可以 `#pragma feature generics` 然后包含任何 STL 头文件。而且我知道它不会与我引入的新 Token 发生冲突，因为 Token 的作用域仅在该文件中，而且如果我想的话我可以将它关闭。现在我意识到，好吧，为什么不直接（你知道的）进行真正快速的演进。
I know I'm not going to break anything because the syntax is gating or that pragma is gating which source lines are exposed to the new features and you know you just try it out I keep turning it over and over and so I've been turning over these function generics, the class generics tuples, choice types and I'm
我知道我不会破坏任何东西，因为语法是在进行守卫（gating），或者那个 pragma 在守卫哪些源代码行向新特性暴露（你知道的）你只要尝试一下，我不断地翻转它，所以我一直在尝试这些函数泛型、类泛型、元组、选择类型，并且我
just trying to go through the checklist because I think on every metric an extended C++ can be competitive with the new features that Carver wants to offer. Without any question about, well, it's not going to support exceptions. It's not going to support, you know, function overloading. Yeah, for me, this is the way to move forward. And I'm actually happy with the successor languages because it means there's other people thinking about what features are important, and then I can go and implement those in my own system. Yeah, so I do agree with you. in practice in the field some of the ways in which
正试图浏览检查清单，因为我认为在各项指标上，扩展的 C++ 完全可以与 Carbon 想要提供的那些新特性相媲美。没有任何关于“好吧，它不支持异常。它不支持（你知道的）函数重载”的疑问。是的，对我来说，这就是向前迈进的方式。而且我实际上对后继语言感到高兴，因为这意味着有其他人在思考哪些特性是重要的，然后我可以去把这些特性实现在我自己的系统中。是的，所以我是同意你的。在实际的现实战场中，我们
we would evolve will become constrained by actual real world impacts of making breaking changes but I think that the C++ evolution process has essentially become paralyzed
演进的某些方式将受到打破性更改（breaking changes）所带来的实际现实影响的限制，但我认为 C++ 的演进过程基本上已经陷入瘫痪
by this fear of what will happen if we make a breaking change. Why is everyone so fixated on breaking changes? That's a good question. I mean, none of this has to, like, interface generics, right? We can Why is everyone so fixated on breaking changes? That's a good question.
由于这种对“如果我们做出打破性更改会发生什么”的恐惧。为什么每个人都如此执着于打破性更改？这是个好问题。我的意思是，这一切都不必像——比如接口泛型，对吧？我们可以为什么每个人都如此执着于打破性更改？这是个好问题。
I mean, none of this has to, like, interface generics, right? We can put these in, and that doesn't break any code. Some types don't break any. People want pattern matching. But doesn't it introduce new keywords? Yeah, so what? Like I said, I'm gating those. Pound, pragma, feature, interface. Your source file.
我的意思是，这一切都不必像——比如接口泛型，对吧？我们可以把这些放进去，而且这不会破坏任何代码。有些类型不会破坏任何代码。人们想要模式匹配。但难道它不会引入新的关键字吗？是的，那又怎样？就像我说的，我在用 `pragma feature interface` 对这些进行守卫。你的源文件。
Your new source file, put that in, right? You don't have to worry about all your system dependencies. This is a successful approach in other languages. Doesn't JavaScript do this? Don't they have... You're the programming language person, Connor. I expect you to know this.
你的新源文件，把这个放进去，对吧？你不必担心你所有的系统依赖项。这在其他语言中是一种成功的方法。JavaScript 不是这样吗？它们难道没有……你才是编程语言专家，康纳（Connor）。我指望你知道这个。
I don't know anything about JavaScript other than they got 17 different ways to compare things and what everyone whines about is triple equals, blah, blah, blah. No, I believe JavaScript has a new strict thing that if you do it, it gives you more modern...
我对 JavaScript 一无所知，除了他们有 17 种不同的方法来比较事物，而每个人都在抱怨的是三等号（triple equals），等等等等。不，我相信 JavaScript 有一个新的严格模式（strict thing），如果你这样做，它会给你更现代的……
I just think there's been too much made about ABI breakage. I don't mean ABI breakage. I just mean evolved... Yes, that's a problem, but I think in a lot of the cases and examples that you have in mind, it's not a question of ABI breakage, I just mean like, you know, evolved, like, yes, that's a problem, but I think in a lot of the cases and examples that you have in mind, it's not a question of ABI breakage, it's just you're introducing new syntax, new... Yeah, so, but what's
我只是觉得人们对 ABI 破坏（ABI breakage）小题大做了。我指的不是 ABI 破坏。我只是指演进……是的，这是一个问题，但我认为在你脑海中的很多情况和例子中，这根本不是一个 ABI 破坏的问题，我只是指（你知道的）演进，就像，是的，这是一个问题，但我认为在你脑海中的很多情况和例子中，这根本不是一个 ABI 破坏的问题，而只是你引入了新的语法，新的……是的，所以，但这有什么
the problem? It doesn't interfere with the old syntax. See, I don't have, I don't see a problem with that. And in fact, there have been language proposals for a thing called Epics, you know, in this space. And I think, at the end of the day, the problem is just that the C++ evolution process moves so slowly.
问题？它不会干扰旧语法。看，我没有、我看不出这有什么问题。事实上，在这个领域里，曾经有过针对一种叫做纪元（Epochs）的东西的语言提案。而且我认为，归根结底，问题仅仅在于 C++ 演进过程的进展实在是太慢了。
I think epochs, I mean, you can debate about what should go in the new epoch. And I think that's really probably where it would slow down. Like people think something, what is best? I don't really believe in codifying like best use, you know, best practice.
我认为纪元，我的意思是，你可以争论什么应该进入新的纪元。而且我认为那大概真的是它会慢下来的地方。就像人们认为某事，什么才是最好的？我其实并不相信将最佳使用（你知道的）、最佳实践编纂成文。
There's another reason why I think you'll get resistance from the committee. I just remembered this. There's this fear of creating dialects. There's this fear that if you have like these modes that you opt into, then C++ becomes
我认为你会遭到委员会阻力的另一个原因是，我刚刚想到了这个。存在着一种对创造方言的恐惧。人们担心，如果你有这些你可以加入的模式，那么 C++ 就会
sharded into multiple different dialects of C++. I personally think that this is not a dialects of C++. I personally think that this is not a reasonable argument because we already have dialects. You've got CUDA.
被碎片化为 C++ 的多个不同方言。我个人认为这不是一个 C++ 的方言。我个人认为这不是一个合理的论据，因为我们已经有方言了。你有 CUDA。
Yes, you have CUDA. But also, you know, between C++ 11, 14, 17, 20, like in the wild, people program in these different time snapshot-esque dialects and and introducing some epics like thing or some some pragma feature thing that lets us introduce new syntax in that people opt into it would just be another form of that um so i don't understand the the concern for that but i think it's really it's a concern that like there must
是的，你有 CUDA。但同时，（你知道的）在 C++11、14、17、20 之间，在野外，人们就在这些不同的时间快照式的方言中进行编程，而且引入类似纪元的东西，或者某种 pragma feature 的东西，让我们能够引入人们自愿选择的新语法，这也只会是那种东西的另一种形式……所以我真的不理解这种担忧，但我认为这确实是一种担忧，即必须
be one unified c++ um and i think i think there are some people who view c++'s devotion to um uh to backwards compatibility at all costs as just like a core aspect of C++. Again, I think this is a I'm trying not to, again, when I see a can of worms, I don't go and open it. I wasn't going to take a bite about this earlier, but we
存在一个统一的 C++……而且我认为，某些人将 C++ 对……对不惜一切代价的向后兼容性的奉献，仅仅视为 C++ 的一个核心方面。再说一次，我认为这是一个……我尽量不去，再说一次，当我看到一个惹麻烦的潘多拉魔盒（can of worms）时，我不会去打开它。我刚才本来不打算就此多说，但我们
got to go back to that. Dude, you built your own C++ compiler. That's like by definition opening up a can of worms. Well, no. I mean, it's something you can make consistent progress at if you just push at it. And this thing about, well, this existential crisis
得回到那个话题上去。老兄，你自己构建了一个 C++ 编译器。这按定义来说就是打开了一个潘多拉魔盒。噢，不。我的意思是，如果你一直去推动它，这是一件你可以取得持续进展的事情。而关于这个东西，关于破坏与旧代码的兼容性或破坏 ABI 的这种
about breaking compatibility with old code or breaking ABI, I don't, I'm just, I'm not personally that interested in that fight. I could go either way. I don't care. If somebody wants to spin a new libc++ that has different data layouts or types in the same namespace,
存在主义危机，我……我个人对这场争论其实不是那么感兴趣。我两边都可以接受。我不在乎。如果有人想要推出一个新的 libc++，它在相同的命名空间中有不同的数据布局或类型，
all right, it's just something to point the compiler at. For me, it doesn't really matter. I think we should let the vendors do what the vendors are going to do. If you're on a managed Linux system, if you're on a CentOS kind of system where you have a professional sysadmin who rolls it out every three years to the organization like that's a fine time i think to break avi if you're going to do it because it's like the whole organization goes in one goes as one unit and then you all debug your problems and then the next month you're back up and running you know I there's ways
好吧，那只是给编译器指明方向而已。对我来说，这其实并不重要。我认为我们应该让供应商去做供应商们要做的事。如果你在一个托管的 Linux 系统上，如果你在一个 CentOS 那样的系统上，在那里你有一个专业的系统管理员，每三年向组织部署一次，那我觉得这是一个打破 ABI 的好时机，如果你打算这么做的话，因为这就像整个组织作为一个整体一起行动，然后你们所有人都在调试你们的问题，接着到了下个月，你们就又恢复运行了，你知道的，我有
to do it but I don't think that saying well we have to break ABI or we have to break backwards compatibility to evolve and there's we can definitely evolve without breaking full code right I agree but the problem is that it requires us to take
办法做到这一点，但我不认为“为了演进，我们必须破坏 ABI，或者我们必须破坏向后兼容性”，而且我们绝对可以在不破坏完整代码的情况下进行演进……是的，我同意，但问题在于这需要我们采取
bold steps to do is that it requires us to take bold steps to do that. Or it requires the committee to take steps that the committee thinks of as bold. I don't know. The reality is that it takes 10 years for any new idea to get into the standard. And so it would take 10 years for us to get pragma feature or epics. But I mean, by saying pragma, I'm indicating I don't really care about standardization.
大胆的步骤去实现，即这需要我们采取大胆的步骤来做到这一点。或者它需要委员会采取委员会认为是很大胆的步骤。我不知道。现实情况是，任何新想法进入标准都需要 10 年时间。所以我们要得到 pragma feature 或 Epochs 需要 10 年时间。但我的意思是，通过说 pragma，我是在表明我真的不在乎标准化。
I've chosen a vendor extension there. My point is just that if we just assume that there's really... My point is that even if all three of us here agree that this is a thing that's pretty straightforward,
我在那里选择了一个供应商扩展。我的观点只是，如果我们只是假设真的……我的观点是，即使在座的我们三个人都认为这是一件非常直接了当的事情，
there's no real reason not to do it. And even if most C++ programmers would agree that we should have something like some mechanism like FX or Fragment feature that would allow us to model language better even if everybody in the committee agreed upon that
也没有什么真正的理由不做它。而且即使大多数 C++ 程序员都会同意我们应该拥有某种机制，比如 Epochs 或 pragma feature，它能让我们更好地对语言建模，即使委员会中的每个人都对此表示同意
and I'm pretty sure that we've taken polls to that effect it would still take 10 years for us to hammer out the details on the committee Right, but the committee, I mean, at the end of the day, companies want to keep compiling their software and make it incrementally better and then sell it or monetize it somehow. And I think for them, what's more important? Is it adhering to the ISO standard or is it being able to compile their software and having confidence that they'll be able to compile it next year as well?
而且我很确凿地知道我们进行过这方面的投票，委员会要想敲定细节仍然需要 10 年时间。对，但委员会，我的意思是，归根结底，公司希望继续编译他们的软件，并使其逐步变得更好，然后将其出售或通过某种方式变现。而且我认为对他们来说，什么更重要？是遵守 ISO 标准，还是能够编译他们的软件，并确信他们明年也能够编译它？
And I think we've conflated the two. Companies have gotten – they're confident that C++ is a long-term thing because it has this international effort behind it. But at the same time, we know now and we're feeling the pinch of Google withdrawing, apparently, quite a bit of investment from Clang. I mean, it seems the pace of Clang development has slowed down. And maybe they're shifting to the successor language. And the interoperability story there is very questionable. So if the question becomes, well, we either jump to Carbon, whatever that may be in the future, which really there's no there's no guarantee to continue to compile our existing code. Or we just suffer with C++20 or like, you know, very slow incremental progress and bleed users and like find it harder and harder to recruit developers.
而我认为我们把这两者混为一谈了。公司已经变得——他们确信 C++ 是一项长期的事情，因为它背后有这种国际化的努力。但与此同时，我们现在知道了，并且我们正在感受到 Google 显然从 Clang 撤回了相当大一部分投资所带来的阵痛。我的意思是，Clang 的开发速度似乎已经放慢了。也许他们正在转向后继语言。那里的互操作性（interoperability）情况非常值得怀疑。所以如果问题变成了，要么我们跃迁到 Carbon（无论未来那会是什么，实际上根本无法保证能继续编译我们现有的代码），要么我们就忍受 C++20，或者（你知道的）非常缓慢的渐进式进展并流失用户，并且发现招募开发人员变得越来越难。
Like those are like two very risky propositions. And I think that the less risky one, which you're right, it's not going to sail through ISO standardization, is to take the ISO standard, yeah, honor it. Like, yeah, I want to implement everything that's in it, you know, and then just give the features that these other rival languages are providing their users. There's no reason we shouldn't have a some type. And you know that. It sounds like you are essentially calling for revolution.
就像那两个是非常有风险的命题。而且我认为风险较低的那一个——你是对的，它不会顺利通过 ISO 标准化——就是接受 ISO 标准，是的，尊重它。就像，是的，我想实现其中包含的一切（你知道的），然后仅仅提供其他竞争语言正在为其用户提供的特性。没有任何理由我们不应该拥有某种类型（some type）。而且你知道的。听起来你基本上是在呼吁一场革命。
No, I'm not calling. What is with this? Connor, do you have to do this with Bryce every time? No, no, no. I mean, I take the most conciliatory tone possible, and he's saying I'm Rose Pierre over here or something. But if you unpack what you're saying, what you're saying is that we should just take ISO C++ as it is, and then compiler vendors should build the features that users want.
不，我没有呼吁。这算怎么回事？康纳，你每次都要对布赖斯（Bryce）这样吗？不，不，不。我的意思是，我采取了尽可能调和的语气，而他却说我是那里的罗伯斯庇尔（Rose Pierre）或者别的什么。但如果你剖析你所说的话，你所说的意思是，我们应该原封不动地接受 ISO C++，然后编译器供应商应该构建用户想要的特性。
That's not revolution. The standard committee can keep making, on a three-year cadence, can keep coming out with a standard. That's fine. And if you're on a team, the project manager of the team could say, well, keep with the standard. Keep with 17. Keep with 20. Keep with 23 or whatever. Or they could say, well, just use this set of new vendor extensions, whatever.
那不是革命。标准委员会可以继续以三年的节奏推出标准。这没问题。如果你在一个团队中，团队的项目经理可以这样说，好吧，坚守标准。坚守 17。坚守 20。坚守 23 或其他什么。或者他们可以这样说，好吧，只使用这套新的供应商扩展，随便什么。
But what people want is they want to be able to – people are afraid of vendor extensions. They want to be able to take their code and use it with any C++ compiler. But that's not the case with Rust. There's one Rust compiler. There's one Python compiler. There's one Swift compiler. There's zero party compilers. Every other language has just
但人们想要的是——人们害怕供应商扩展。他们希望能够拿走他们的代码，并在任何 C++ 编译器上使用它。但 Rust 可不是这样的。只有一个 Rust 编译器。只有一个 Python 编译器。只有一个 Swift 编译器。零方编译器（zero party compilers）。其他每种语言都只有
one compiler. Are you advocating even more interesting position of that we should just have one C++ compiler? No. Unbelievable. No, no, no. But why not? You have such isobrain. No, no, no, but why not? You have such isobrain, it's... No, no, but why shouldn't we have one C++ compiler?
一个编译器。你是在主张一个更有意思的立场，即我们应该只拥有一个 C++ 编译器吗？不。难以置信。不，不，不。但为什么不呢？你太有 ISO 脑了。不，不，不，但为什么不呢？你太有 ISO 脑了，这……不，不，但为什么我们不该拥有一个 C++ 编译器呢？
Look, because if that was the case, I would never have been able to write mine if there was some law where... I'm not saying there should be some law. Some enforcement mechanism where the SWAT comes in and like... Well, if we're going to have one C++ compiler, it should be circle. Oh, well, yeah. Great. Great. No, I think it's important that everyone...
听着，因为如果真是那样的话，如果有某种法律规定……我并不是说应该有什么法律。某种执法机制，特警冲进来……好吧，如果我们要拥有一个 C++ 编译器，那它就应该是 Circle。哦，好吧，是的。太棒了。太棒了。不，我认为对每个人来说这很重要……
Look, I'm not against the successor languages. Yeah? I think, you know, they say carbon is an experiment. Like, good. I think the scientific method of trying things out and trying to learn from that is good. I want to do what they're doing to learn from that is good. I want to do what they're doing, but from a different direction. For me, compatibility is really important.
听着，我并不反对后继语言。是吗？我认为，（你知道的）他们说 Carbon 是一个实验。很好。我认为尝试事物并试图从中学习的科学方法是好的。我想做他们正在做的事情来从中学习是好的。我想从不同的方向做他们正在做的事情。对我来说，兼容性非常重要。
For me, I'm extending ISO C++. I have the same features that Carbon has in mind, and I'm just putting them into the C++ compiler. Okay, but what if another compiler wanted to really like one of the features that you were doing and wanted to put it into their compiler?
对我来说，我正在扩展 ISO C++。我拥有 Carbon 心目中的相同特性，而我正把它们放进 C++ 编译器中。好的，但是如果另一个编译器非常想要你正在做的其中一个特性，并希望把它放进他们的编译器里呢？
And then they wanted some mechanism, like, by which the two of you could agree upon how the feature works. Okay. That would be good. That would be, that would indicate a lot more, like, ambition and creativity in the C++ compiler space than there is now. Yeah. more like ambition and creativity in the c++ compiler space than there is now yeah i mean i think there i think maybe you're saying the committee is afraid of like too many people
然后他们希望有一种机制，比如你们两个可以借此就该特性如何运作达成一致。好的。那会很好。那将表明，在 C++ 编译器领域中，比现在有更多的野心和创造力。是的。在 C++ 编译器领域中有更多的野心和创造力，比现在要多。是的，我的意思是，我想那里，也许你在说委员会害怕太多人
doing creative things is this what it um but that's like not that hasn't been the case really in 20 some years committee's afraid of too many people doing too different too many things um i i think the committee wants to to be bolder and the committee wants to be bolder, and the committee wants to do creative things, and I think pretty much everybody in the committee has good intentions. I think the committee's problems are that there's, one, there's just too many people. There's too many perspectives.
做有创造力的事，这是……但那并非事实，在过去二十多年里确实不是这样的情况。委员会害怕太多人做太不同的、太多的事情……我、我认为委员会想要变得更大胆，并且委员会想要变得更大胆，并且委员会想要做有创造力的事，而且我认为委员会里的几乎所有人都有好的意图。我认为委员会的问题在于，第一，人实在是太多了。观点实在是太多了。
I don't think that you can have your core decision-making body be like 350 people. I think there should be like eight people at most that make final decisions on things. It's not that there's too many voices hearing everybody's opinions is good but there's too many there's too many like deciding voices um and i also think that there's like because of that there's far too many constraints because like we've got like 350 folks that you got to convince um and and everybody has like very different goals and objectives um and you know our goal is to build like you know we're all built around this building consensus and so i think oftentimes we bend over backwards
我不认为你可以让你的核心决策机构有 350 人左右。我认为最终对事情做出决定的人最多应该只有八个人。倒不是说声音太多了，倾听每个人的意见是好的，但有太多的、有太多的决定性声音……而且我还认为，正因为如此，存在着太多的限制，因为我们有大约 350 个人需要你去说服……并且每个人都有非常不同的目标和宗旨……而且（你知道的）我们的目标是建立——你知道的，我们都是围绕着建立共识来构建的，所以我认为往往我们会过分妥协，
and try to satisfy you know whoever happens to be objecting loudly to what we want to do. And it ends up where you've got this thing that is pulled in 20 different directions to satisfy these constraints. Yeah, I think that's how it plays out. That's probably an accurate dynamic. You would know, I'm not involved with any of this. But on the other hand, when there's a new proposal that's like a core core language proposal you know i if it's if it seems to me like well defined i will implement it yeah and
并试图满足（你知道的）任何恰好对我们想做的事情大声反对的人。结果就是，你得到了一个被拉向 20 个不同方向的东西，仅仅为了满足这些限制。是的，我认为事情就是这样发展的。这可能是一个准确的动态。你当然知道，我没有参与任何这些。但另一方面，当有一个新的提案，它就像是一个核心的核心语言提案，你知道的，如果在我看来它定义得很明确，我就会实现它，是的，而且
even if i'm not that interested in it and i think that we should have a more liberal attitude which is i was saying at the beginning of this even if it's not about standardization as the ultimate goal but it's just like like the talk i gave in in Asperger's. Like you said, you're, you're angry that a lot of people had objections to it. I, I felt that it was such a good, the issue that I had is that I think people fail to appreciate, um, the, the vision that you have and how much you've driven forward
即使我对此不是那么感兴趣，我也认为我们应该采取更宽容的态度，就像我在本集开头所说的，即使它不是以标准化为终极目标，但它就像——就像我在阿斯佩尔（Asperger）做的演讲那样。就像你说的，你、你很生气很多人对此有异议。我、我真的觉得那是如此之好，我遇到的问题是，我认为人们没有能够欣赏，呃，你的远见，以及你将
the world of C++ compilers. If for no other reason than by demonstrating to people that it's not some big, scary thing that there's only three people in the world
C++ 编译器世界推动向前了多少。如果不是为了别的，至少是通过向人们展示这不是什么庞大、可怕的事情，世界上只有三个人
and you need these huge teams to do. You're just one guy who went off and built the C++ compiler. And when you find a proposal that you find interesting, you can go and rapidly prototype it. And I think it's been very refreshing and eye-opening for the C++ world to see that that is possible. And it, it,
并且你需要庞大的团队来完成。你只是一个独自去构建了 C++ 编译器的家伙。而当你发现一个你觉得有趣的提案时，你可以迅速将其做成原型。而且我认为对于 C++ 世界来说，看到这是可能的，是非常耳目一新且大开眼界的。并且它、它，
not everybody, I think I, I certainly, I don't agree with every aspect of your vision of, of the specifics of what you have in mind. But it seemed like to me, like that was sort of besides the point that you were showing us a world of possibilities and you don't have to agree with every possibility that sean showed in that talk but that world where we can have all these possibilities that's very exciting and then a bunch of people came up and
并不是每个人——我想我、我当然不同意你的愿景的每一个方面、关于你脑海中的具体细节。但在我看来，这似乎并不重要，重要的是你向我们展示了一个充满可能性的世界，你不需要同意肖恩（Sean）在那个演讲中展示的每一个可能性，但那个我们可以拥有所有这些可能性的世界，是非常令人兴奋的。然后一群人走上前来
asked questions nitpicking like well i don't like this and that and that and it just it made me so sad because i'm like but you're missing the point the point is that we have so many options that we can move faster, we can explore all of these things, we can make the language better. And people just wanted to focus on the language. Yeah, I think I said something like, I'm not trying to convince
挑刺提问，比如“嗯，我不喜欢这个、那个和那个”，这真的让我感到很难过，因为我在想，“可是你们没有抓住重点”。重点在于我们有如此多的选项，我们可以走得更快，我们可以探索所有这些事情，我们可以让语言变得更好。而人们却只想把焦点放在语言上。是的，我想我说过类似的话，我并不是在试图说服
you of any individual feature. I'm just trying to convince you that incremental change will make the language better and more expensive. Right, right. And what made me sad was that people didn't focus on that. People focused on the rules. Well, I think it's just like, take a beat. You know, like, I delivered like 90 minutes of like rapid fire.
任何单个特性。我只是想让你相信，渐进式的改变会让这门语言更好、更具扩展性。对吧，对吧。让我难过的是，大家没有关注这一点。大家把焦点都放在了规则上。我觉得这就好比，大家冷静一下。你知道的，就像我发表了大约90分钟的连珠炮式的演讲。
It was like, here's like 20 new features, right? And just like sleep on it at least. And try to look at it from a different angle. Because I think there's a lot of preconception about what metaprogramming should look like. And my stuff didn't look like that. It might have looked more like JavaScript or something else. I mean, I didn't really have any individual idiom. I was just trying to do things that would cut through the nonsense we deal with on a daily basis if you're writing standard library code.
就像是，这里有20个新特性，对吧？至少花点时间消化一下。试着从不同的角度来看待它。因为我认为大家对于元编程应该是什么样子的，存在很多先入为主的观念。而我的东西看起来并不那样。它可能看起来更像JavaScript或其他东西。我的意思是，我其实并没有什么固定的惯用法。我只是想做一些事情，能够切断我们在编写标准库代码时每天都要面对的那些废话。
And in that sense, it was very non-ideological. I was just trying to get to complete the problem, finish the problem. I think people just need to adjust their brains a little bit to sit back and say, does this help me
从这个意义上说，它非常没有意识形态色彩。我只是想解决问题，完成问题。我认为人们只需要稍微调整一下大脑，坐下来想一想，这是否能帮我
solve my problem, as opposed to, does this conform to some design ideology? I think for a long time, C++ has does this conform to some design ideology and i think i think for a long time c++ has been too much in that design ideology mindset whereas other languages they don't have these scruples really yeah like if there's something that's super useful like they'll put it in there even if it doesn't make any like theoretical sense and i know it going back to the epics i think the epics thing is a perfect example of that. One of the biggest objections to Toons and Minnick epics has been this ideology that
解决问题，而不是这是否符合某种设计意识形态？我认为长期以来，C++一直过于陷入这种设计意识形态的心态中，而其他语言则没有这些顾虑，真的，是的，如果有什么东西超级有用，他们就会把它加进去，即使它在理论上没有任何意义。我知道，回到epics的话题，我认为epics就是一个绝佳的例子。对Toons和Minnick epics最大的反对意见之一就是这种意识形态，即
we can't have dialects or subsets of C++, that it needs to be one coherent vision of a language. And I'm sure that there's a motivation for that, um the the sort of the absolutism of like that keeping us from doing the possibly the one thing that could really unlock our future is i think very uh very troubling and and it's the way that i've heard that concern expressed has really been sort of this like theoretical, well, you know, we might shard the community in the future if we introduce some notion of, you know, subsets or variants or dialects.
我们不能有C++的方言或子集，它必须是统一的语言愿景。我确信这是有动机的，呃，那种绝对主义的态度阻止了我们去做可能是唯一能真正开启我们未来的事情，这我认为非常、非常令人不安，而且，我听到这种担忧被表达出来的方式，真的有点像那种理论上的，嗯，你知道的，如果我们引入了某种子集、变体或方言的概念，我们可能会在未来分裂社区。
And so we shouldn't do or encourage that. And there's a lot of things like that where the committee is presented with some option and that option would fix a real problem that we have. And we don't do that thing because of some theoretical problem that might happen if we do that. And it's like, the house is on fire, but we don't want to put up the fire because you know that could create some other problem well maybe we should focus on the problems that we
所以我们不应该这样做或鼓励这样做。有很多这样的事情，委员会被呈上某种选项，而这个选项可以解决我们真正面临的问题。我们没有做那件事，是因为可能会发生的某种理论上的问题。这就好比，房子着火了，但我们不想灭火，因为你知道那可能会引发其他问题。也许我们应该把注意力集中在我们面临的问题上
have there are i think also we lose sight that there are you know like a million full-time c++ programmers and it's their livelihood yeah and um you know if you can make them incrementally more productive, you can make them 5%, 10% more productive. That is like industry changing. That is when you integrate over all of the effort going in, that is, you know, so many billions of dollars of value added. Yeah. And I don't think we should like, you know, veto features without really considering the consequence of what we're doing there. But one of the sad things, and I think you will be intimately familiar with this, is big tech companies so drastically undervalue developer productivity. And this is one of the reasons why there are so few like compiler front-end
我们认为，我们还忽视了一点，那就是有大约一百万名全职C++程序员，这是他们的生计，是的，而且，你知道的，如果你能让他们的生产力稍微提高一点，让他们提高5%、10%的生产力。这就改变了整个行业。当你在所有投入的工作上进行积分时，你知道的，那是价值数十亿美元的增量。是的。而且我认为我们不应该在没有真正考虑我们正在做的事情的后果的情况下，就否决特性。但令人悲伤的事情之一，我想你对此会非常熟悉，那就是大科技公司极大地低估了开发人员的生产力。这也是为什么相对于编译器后端工程师而言，只有极少数的编译器前端
engineers relative to you know compiler backend engineers um this is why like you have so few people working on um uh like standard libraries and build systems and stuff like that because um at the end of the day a lot lot of big tech companies' perspective is like, oh, well, you know, it's painful to write the code. Like, that's okay. Like, we've got good developers. Like, they'll be able to do it. And it's like, it's exactly what you said.
工程师，你知道的，这就是为什么从事标准库和构建系统等工作的人如此之少，因为归根结底，许多大科技公司的观点是，哦，好吧，你知道的，编写代码很痛苦。没关系，我们有优秀的开发人员，他们能够做到。这就正如你所说的那样。
You know, if you make all your programmers 5% more efficient, that is going to save you so much. And it is sad that, it is sad the degree to which thing technologies like compilers are undervalued um uh you know especially in this day and age there used to be a lot more you know c++ compiler companies and um now there's really only a few there's only really one front-end company left that's EDG.
你知道的，如果你让所有的程序员效率提高5%，那将为你节省巨额成本。令人悲伤的是，诸如编译器之类技术的价值被严重低估了，尤其是在这个时代。过去有很多C++编译器公司，而现在真正剩下的只有几家，唯一真正剩下的前端公司就是EDG。
There's just not the money in the developer tool space that there is in other sectors. If I go to a programming language conference like C++ Now or CppCon, back when I went to CppCon, you go and you see like who's sponsoring it and like how big like the vendor space is and it's not that large. And then you go to a conference like supercomputing or like a conference that like sells where they sell hardware and it's like there's so much fun in it. The whole exhibition hall is been yeah yeah switches and things yeah um but it's just we just don't we don't we invest in the physical tools that we give to programmers we don't
开发工具领域的资金并不像其他行业那样充裕。如果我去参加像C++ Now或CppCon这样的编程语言会议，回想起我以前去CppCon的时候，你去看看是谁在赞助它，供应商的展位有多大，其实并没有那么大。然后你去参加像超级计算或者销售硬件的会议，哇，那里资金太充足了。整个展厅都是开关和各种设备，但是，我们就是没有，我们投资了给程序员的物理工具，却并没有
invest in the uh the um the software tools that we give to programmers as much as we should now okay but you but you never answered the question what do you think of cpp yeah well so i was gonna say we've been talking about, um, carbon and circle and C plus plus. So I guess first question is, did you watch the closing keynote? And then second question. Yeah. Thoughts on CPP front. And, uh, hopefully the answer to the first one is yes. And then you can give a little, cause I'm sure that some of our listeners have no idea what we're talking about because they have not seen that keynote yet. I did not watch the keynote. Wait, wait, Conor, did you watch
像我们应该的那样，去投资给程序员的软件工具。现在，好吧，但你从来没有回答过这个问题，你对cpp怎么看？嗯，我是想说，我们一直在讨论Carbon、Circle和C++。所以我想第一个问题是，你看了闭幕主题演讲吗？然后是第二个问题。对CPP front有什么看法？而且，希望第一个问题的回答是“是”。然后你可以简单讲讲，因为我敢肯定我们的一些听众完全不知道我们在谈论什么，因为他们还没有看过那个主题演讲。我没有看主题演讲。等等，等等，Connor，你看过
the keynote? I did, yes. Okay. I participated in Herb's keynote from the previous year where he showed the pattern matching proposal which I implemented in Circle and after I sent him that code, he sent me the CPP
主题演讲了吗？我看过，是的。我参与了Herb去年的主题演讲，他在演讲中展示了模式匹配提案，我在Circle中实现了这个提案。在我把代码发给他之后，他把CPP
to doc which is not public and that's like 120 pages so I read the doc so I have more information than wait so what this was back at right after last year's CPP gone maybe before like probably in August of last year interesting because this is a uh what do you call it, an editorial comment that I had sort of, I thought that this mostly was a reaction. Oh no, this has been, I mean, CPP2 has been around for like a while. Herb's been working on this for a while. I think I first read of it in... Herb should have, he should have done this announcement like a couple years ago. Well, this is, I think, I think there's always like this, this challenge when you've got this new project, like when is it ready to show? Well, it's not ready to show,
to doc发给了我，这不是公开的，大约有120页，所以我读了这份文档，所以我掌握的信息比...等等，这回到了去年CPPCon刚结束的时候，也许在这之前，可能是去年八月份。有趣的是，这是一个，你叫它什么来着，我某种程度上把它看作是一种编辑评论，我以为这主要是某种反应。哦不，这个已经，我是说CPP2已经存在一段时间了。Herb做这个已经有一段时间了。我想我第一次读到它是在...Herb本应该，他本应该在几年前就发布这个公告的。嗯，这，我认为，我认为当你有这样一个新项目时，总是存在这种挑战，什么时候准备好展示？嗯，它还没有准备好展示，
but you should show it still. Yeah, exactly. But I think that that's really hard for some people. Yeah, it's fine. Yeah, but I think, you know, Carbon, I think, picked a good sort of time. One thing that Carbon did was, Carbon didn't
但你仍然应该展示它。对，没错。但我认为这对某些人来说真的很难。是的，没关系。是的，但我认为，你知道的，Carbon，我认为挑选了一个很好的时机。Carbon所做的一件事情是，Carbon并不是在它构思出来的第一时间就
go public as soon as it was conceived of, but they had a pretty long period where they brought in more and more. I think Carbon was too early announced. You think it was too early? It didn't even have not equal operator.
公开了，但他们有一个相当长的时期，引入了越来越多的人。我认为Carbon过早地发布了。你觉得太早了吗？它甚至连不等于运算符都没有。
It didn't have less than. It didn't have integers other than 32-bit. It didn't have floats. It's not like a... It can't compile anything. There's no compiler. I think they should have got cogeneration. But I agree that CPP2, I think, would be far more effective and more likely to gain traction as an idea if it had been announced earlier.
它没有小于运算符。它除了32位之外没有别的整数。它没有浮点数。它不像是一个...它什么也编译不了。没有编译器。我认为他们应该先搞定代码生成。但我同意，如果CPP2能早点宣布，作为一种理念，它会更有效，也更有可能获得支持。
I think ditto with things like metaclasses, etc. Yeah, because I looked at the repository and it started in mid-2021 or late-2021. And almost all the code contributions happen since July. So just like three months ago. So when I was talking to her, he had just started, like this was last summer. He had just started that repository. And like he said, it's, it's a,
我觉得元类等东西也是如此。是的，因为我查看了代码库，它始于2021年中期或2021年底。几乎所有的代码贡献都发生在7月之后。也就是大概三个月前。所以当我与Herb交流时，他才刚刚开始，那是去年夏天。他才刚刚开始那个代码库。就像他说的，它是一个，
I guess he's calling it a transpiler, but it doesn't like, it's not a compiler. So it's a one way, it's a one-way, it's a one-directional thing, which is not, you can't actually make software that way, right? Like, textually, if you call a function, you have to know what the result object type is of that function. There's no way to determine that from this architecture he has. So it's really just a way to show the syntax, I think.
我想他称之为转译器（transpiler），但它并不像，它不是一个编译器。所以它是一个单向的东西，你实际上不能用这种方式来构建软件，对吧？从文本层面来看，如果你调用一个函数，你必须知道该函数的返回对象类型是什么。通过他所采用的这种架构，根本无法确定这一点。所以我觉得它真的只是展示语法的一种方式。
The more of the, the real values in that document, which I don't think he's made public still now. Yeah. So that is, I guess this is kind of the same. I'm not going to say criticism, but I'm going to say this is a different philosophy I have from carbon or from CBP too,
那份文档中更多真正的价值，我想他到现在还没有公开。所以，我想这有点类似。我不会称之为批评，但我要说的是，这是我与Carbon或CPP2不同的哲学，
which is we can, we can disaggregate these features like Herb's feature, major feature, I think is the parameter passing. He has these directives like, you's major feature, I think, is the parameter passing. He has these directives, like in, in, out. Yeah, yeah. And they may compile to different things. They may emit an R value reference, or it may emit a deep copy or a pass-by value if it's a trivial type.
也就是我们可以将这些特性解构，比如Herb的特性，主要特性我认为是参数传递。他有这些指令，比如in、out。是的，是的。它们可能会编译成不同的东西。它们可能会生成一个右值引用，或者如果是一个常量类型（trivial type），它可能会生成一个深拷贝或按值传递。
You can disaggregate that, and can say, this is a C++ proposal and we can put that into an existing C++ compiler. And it's just a few like new bits of syntax. And I think that's, if you want to show like that this is a better way
你可以将其解构，然后说，这是一个C++提案，我们可以将其放入现有的C++编译器中。它只是一些新的语法片段。我认为，如果你想展示这是一种更好的参数传递方式，
to pass parameters that leads to less bugs, great. And let's fold it into existing code and we can even rewrite just a map or something like that with these new parameter directives. I kind of wish that he had focused more on the features, to disaggregate the features of CPP2 and focus on the individual. And he has kind of.
能够减少Bug，那就太好了。让我们把它折叠进现有的代码中，我们甚至可以用这些新的参数指令重写一个map什么的。我有点希望他能更多地关注特性本身，将CPP2的特性解构并专注于各个单独的特性。他其实也算做到了这一点。
He does have a proposal for static exceptions. And I think there's that yeah there is a metaclassical proposal although these are again like five years ago which is when he started this this grand vision i think it's kind of like um you know rodan you know like the whole gates of hell tableau but like people don't want the whole tableau they just want the thinker so you know herb just like give us the thinker. And the whole tableau is a little bit much to buy into. If you care about it. And just in case our listener is not up to date with this announcement,
他确实有一个关于静态异常的提案。我认为确实有，还有一个元类提案，尽管这些又是五年前提出来的，那是他开始这个宏大愿景的时候。我觉得这有点像罗丹的《地狱之门》浮雕，但人们并不想要整幅浮雕，他们只想要“思想者”。所以，Herb，给我们“思想者”就行了。整幅浮雕对大家来说有点难以接受。如果你在乎的话。为了防止我们的听众对这个公告还不了解，
basically this CPP front slash CPP2 thing is, I don't even really know if it's, you can call it a proposal. Herb in his talk says that's just his sandbox or, you know, for, you know, it's his can call it a proposal herb in his talk says it's just his sandbox or you know for you know it's his sort of dreamland future where he's introducing a whole new syntax and then calling it not a language but as sean mentioned like it transpiles to c++ and it's just a different file extension so you you know write this new syntax, call the file dot CPP two, and then it'll generate a dot CPP file, which then ends up getting, getting compiled. And there's a bunch of new fancy stuff, the inode stuff that just got mentioned, which if you've
基本上这个CPP front/CPP2的东西，我甚至不知道这能不能算是一个提案。Herb在演讲中说这只是他的沙盒，或者你知道的，为了，你知道的，这是他的梦想之地，他在那里引入了一种全新的语法，然后不称其为一门语言，但正如Sean所提到的，它会被转译为C++，它只是一个不同的文件扩展名，所以你可以编写这种新语法，将文件命名为.CPP2，然后它会生成一个.CPP文件，最终被编译。里面有很多花哨的新东西，也就是刚提到的inode相关的东西，如果你
watched Herb's keynote, I think from the previous year, a couple of years ago, he talked about that potentially being something that could show up in C++. um yeah he unifies i think like function and lambda syntax and there's a bunch of stuff in it yeah and it's i thought the most i don't know the most curious thing but at the beginning of the talk and it might might actually be like the most i don't know what the word is concerning but i was just like wow it made me think of java from 2018 when i was at oracle hq for like a java 13 party and one of the people presenting on stage who is like a key java contributor i can't remember his name i can find it and put it in the show notes he went on a big he got a question from someone in the audience about like some feature in scala and then he went on like a 10 minute monologue of how you know java's not dead
看过Herb的主题演讲，我想是前一年的，几年前的，他谈到那可能是会出现在C++中的东西。嗯，是的，我认为他统一了函数和lambda语法，里面还有一堆东西。是的，我觉得最，我不知道是最奇怪的，但在演讲开始时，这实际上可能是最，我不知道该用什么词，最令人担忧的，但我当时就想，哇，这让我想起了2018年的Java，当时我在甲骨文总部参加Java 13派对，台上的一位演讲者是一位核心Java贡献者，我不记得他的名字了，我可以找到它并把它放在节目说明里。他被台下观众问到一个关于Scala中某个特性的问题，然后他就开始了一场长达10分钟的独白，讲述Java是如何没有死的
and you know you can't keep just asking for all these cool features and these functional languages and i was just like, whoa, man, like it was just a question. Like, why are you getting so upset just because someone mentioned Scala? Cause I'm guessing clearly these people that work on Java get a lot of questions. How come we can't have language X language feature X and in job.
，你知道的，你不能一直要求所有这些很酷的特性和函数式语言，我当时就想，哇，老兄，这只是一个问题。为什么有人提到Scala你就会这么沮丧？因为我猜这些在Java上工作的人显然经常被问到：为什么我们不能在Java中有语言特性X？
And so what Herb said at the beginning, when maybe I'll even, I'll cut the audio clip in, uh, is he basically begs the audience. He says, please don't leave C++. And I was like, wait, what? You're at a keynote talk of the largest, or I guess maybe not by this year's numbers.
所以Herb在开始时所说的话，也许我甚至会把这段音频剪辑插进来，他基本上是在恳求观众。他说，请不要离开C++。我当时就想，等等，什么？你是在一场最大规模的主题演讲中，或者我猜也许按今年的数据算不上最大，
But, you know, it's sort of known as the, for however many years, the premier North American, I guess it's only one of two, now three. Anyways, point is, it's a big conference. And the closing keynote is like asking the attendees of the conference like that, that was being, cause like, and like I said, like as soon as he said that, it made me think of like this meetup that I went to at Oracle HQ where, you know, the, this guy was basically upset and saying, you know, Java's not dead. We got millions of people, blah, blah, blah. And I was like, well, I mean, the second you start saying something's not like, it's like, you know, when they say, oh, smart people don't say they're smart. You know, it's like, it's one of those things it's anyways it was so like i said i'm not
但是，你知道的，多年来它被称为北美最具声望的——我想现在它是仅有的两个之一，现在是三个。无论如何，重点是，这是一个大型会议。而闭幕主题演讲就像是在向会议的与会者这样恳求，因为正如我所说，他一说完，就让我想起了我去甲骨文总部参加的一个聚会，那家伙基本上很沮丧，然后说，你知道的，Java没有死。我们有几百万用户，巴拉巴拉。我当时就想，好吧，我的意思是，你一开始说某某没有死，这就好比，你知道的，当他们说，哦，聪明的人不会说自己聪明。你知道的，这就像是那种情况。不管怎样，这太，就像我说的，我
sure if the word is concerning but i just i i thought it was odd to um and that made me even think is like is this like actually like some inflection point and is it the beginning of the end we're seeing all these suggestions i think it's definitely an inflection point. I think whether it's the beginning of language space is going to, is everyone going to be writing in circle? Is it going to be C plus plus is just going to be in slow decline or tune in next time to hear Sean's answer and part two of this episode. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
不确定这个词是不是“令人担忧”，但我只是，我只是觉得很奇怪，这甚至让我觉得，这实际上是某种拐点吗？这是末日的开始吗？我们看到了所有这些建议，我认为这绝对是一个拐点。我认为，无论是语言空间的发展，是否每个人都会用Circle编写？还是C++将陷入缓慢衰减？请收听下期节目，听听Sean对本集第二部分的回答。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢本期节目，祝你有美好的一天。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。